UNIX wurde von einem großen Programmern in Bell Laboratories entwickelt. Und das ist heute UNIX, ein großartiges Ort für Minikomputer-Software. Was UNIX nicht ist, ist was AT&T und viele andere Unternehmen versuchen, in die Linie zu machen, das ultimative Mikrokomputer-Operationssystem. Aber ich weiß, dass Anwendungen, die für UNIX auf einer Maschine sind, nicht immer auf einer anderen arbeiten. Es gibt unkommpatible UNIX-Dialekte, die gelohren. UNIX ist ein Nutzer-Hostel-Operationssystem, dramatisch kurz auf der Software. Das ist meine Meinung.
Hier hört CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 209. Ausgabe unseres kleinen Gesprächsformats. Und wer hier schon etwas länger zuhört oder vor allem auch schon ganz am Anfang mal reingelauscht hat, der wird wissen, dass wir ja schon immer eine ganze Menge sehr technische Themen behandelt haben, auch wenn sich das ganze Spektrum schon ein bisschen breiter aufgefächert hat und dass er auch sollte. Nichtsdestotrotz kehre ich jetzt mal wieder so ein bisschen an den Anfang zurück und nehme so ein Thema auf, was eigentlich schon immer hätte mal ein Thema sein können, nämlich Linux. Um genauer zu sein, wollen wir uns mal anschauen, das Linux-System, weil reden kann man da aber eine ganze Menge und man kann ganz tief in irgendwelche Kernelfragen eintauchen. Das soll jetzt nicht so ganz das Thema sein, sondern wie lebt dieses System, wie funktioniert dieses System, was macht es aus? Ja, und dazu begrüße ich Lennart, Lennart Poettering. Hallo. Lennart, du bist Hacker, oder?
So kann man das ausdrücken, ja.
Und irgendwie auch schon immer?
Oh ja, schon seitdem ich sehr jung war, ja. Aber nicht Hacker mehr in dem Sinn, dass ich wirklich Dinge hacken würde, eigentlich mehr alleine, dass ich Software entwickle.
Ich trenne das eine von dem anderen nicht so. Das ist ja so ein populärer Blick, dass wir hacken jetzt immer nur irgendwas mit, was weiß ich, Intrusion oder Security zu tun hat.
Obwohl, das ist eine Lüge. Ich habe sogar mal mehr gemacht, als nur entwickelt irgendwie. Ich habe mal einen Hack gemacht, der in der Presse sogar aufgetaucht ist, aber...
Was war das?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich darüber reden will. Die Polizei war aktiv in der Sache. Aber ich nehme an, das ist inzwischen sowieso verirrt. Aber in Hamburg gab es so U-Bahnen, die Displays, und solche Werbedisplays. Wir haben die mal manipuliert, weil es so einfach war. Das war eigentlich sehr schöpisch.
Wie kam man da ran?
Na ja, das war vor langen, langen Jahren. Da war alles offen. Man ist einfach reinspaziert.
Du meinst W-Laden oder Türen?
W-Laden. Nee, nee, nee. Wir haben schon alles digital gemacht. Aber das war ganz lustig.
Wenn die Türen offen stehen, dann geht natürlich auch einer rein. So ist es.
Ganz genau. Es war schwierig, das nicht zu tun.
Ja, aber ich habe eigentlich schon immer den Blick gehabt, so hacken ist eher so eine Grundeinstellung, wie man so an das Leben herangeht und natürlich auch an die Technologie im Besonderen. Und ich denke, das drückt sich auch eher in so einer gewissen Respektlosigkeit aus, mit der man sich selbst an Sachen heranführt. Der nächste schon.
Ja, ich glaube, Respektlosigkeit ist was Großartiges. Also insbesondere auch, wenn man Software entwickelt. Die besten Hacker sind immer die, die keinen Respekt haben von dem, was irgendwie vorher war und die sich keine Mühe geben, irgendwie den Leuten zu gefallen oder sowas, sondern einfach machen, was sie für richtig halten. Man muss schon so einen Charakter haben, dass man respektlos ist, wenn man erfolgreich sein will. Insbesondere in einer freien Software, weil die Leute alle halt irgendwie ihre Egos haben und irgendwie manchmal sauer reagieren können, wenn man ihnen auf die Füße tritt. Aber das, glaube ich, ist unbedingt notwendig.
Aber du meinst jetzt nicht respektlos vor den Menschen, sondern respektlos sozusagen vor dem technischen Status Quo?
Ich glaube, sagen wir mal, auch respektlos vor Menschen, die irgendwie zu stolz auf Dinge sind, die sie lieber nicht stolz sein sollten. Also keine Ahnung. Also wenn mir zum Beispiel jemand das System, der groß am Mist ist, dann habe ich damit überhaupt kein Problem. Das finde ich irgendwie sympathisch, dass jemand mir das direkt sagt. Und ich glaube, das ist irgendwie diese randegehendste Weise. Also zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, so falscher Respekt gegenüber Leuten, die halt irgendwie schon lange die Community geführt haben oder sowas, halte ich für eine ganz gefährliche Sache, weil das heißt ja nur, dass die Leute nicht hinterfragen, was die Leute tun. Aber man sollte immer alles hinterfragen, wenn es um technische Dinge geht, weil letztendlich kommt es darauf an, dass irgendwie man sollte sich nicht von irgendwie so persönlichen Respekt leiten lassen, technische Dinge nicht zu hinterfragen. Das halte ich für ganz wichtig. Und das meine ich, also auch auf mich selbst bezogen.
Du bist ja gar nicht in Deutschland geboren worden.
Ja, ich bin in Guatemala geboren, vor langen, langen Jahren.
Aber da warst du nicht so lange.
Da war ich, bis ich eins war. Aufgewachsen bin ich aber in Brasilien. Aber da bin ich jetzt auch schon lange nicht mehr.
Aufgewachsen heißt, bis zu welchem Alter?
Bis ich zwölf war oder sowas.
Okay.
Und dann bin ich nach Deutschland. Aber auch nicht nach Berlin, sondern nach Hamburg. Und dann bin ich, vor jetzt acht Jahren, bin ich nach Berlin.
Mit zwölf, von... Was war das, Rio?
Von Rio, genau, nach Hamburg. Du bist schon... Bisschen wechsel, ja.
Was war das, einfach?
Weiß ich nicht, ich bin ja nun doch sehr deutsch, glaube ich. Leider, weiß nicht. Und insofern, nein, es war nicht sehr schwierig. Aber Brasilien ist großartig. Also irgendwie, ich gehe auch immer gerne wieder zurück nach Brasilien, weil das Wetter viel besser ist. Und das Rindfleisch viel besser ist.
Und Brasilien hat eigentlich auch eine relativ starke Open-Source-Szene, oder?
Ja, ich war dieses Jahr sogar auf der Fizzle in Brasilien, in Südbrasilien. Und die sind ganz gut dabei. Also wirklich ganz positiv zu sehen. Und die nehmen das auch teilweise noch ganz anders wahr, als das in, sagen wir mal, Europa und USA der Fall ist. Weil für die ist das auch immer so was wie Selbstermächtigung, sagen wir mal so. Also so eine Art von irgendwie, die Software, die ermöglicht denen halt viel mehr als uns, das irgendwie bewusst ist, an allem teilzuhaben, was irgendwie Hightech ist. Also irgendwie hier kann sich sowieso jeder alles kaufen, was er will und kann Buch lesen und alles, gar kein Problem. Aber irgendwie freie Software hat doch den großen Vorteil, dass irgendwie jeder wirklich das einfach reingucken kann und ohne Probleme auf denselben Stand kommen kann. Wenn er irgendwie geistige Fähigkeiten dazu hat. Aber das reicht dann schon aus, wie irgendwie alle anderen auf der Welt. Und das merkt man da auch irgendwie, dass es eine Ermächtigungssache ist. Die haben überall in Brasilien zum Beispiel diese IT-Zentren aufgebaut, wo irgendwie selbst Kinder aus der Verwerlers ein Computer herangeführt werden. Es sind natürlich nicht alles Hacker, die da hinstellen. Aber es ist schon irgendwie ganz positiv zu sehen, dass es irgendwie...
Aber es ist Teil der Kultur.
Naja, es ist immer noch verschwindend gering, glaube ich. Aber die Regierung fördert es extrem. Auf der Konferenz da unten in Südbrasilien war auch immer Lula, als er noch Präsident war, ist er auch immer vorbeigekommen. Das ist schon eine ganz andere Sache. Ich möchte mal sehen, wo hier auf einer Linus-Konferenz die Bundeskanzlerin vorbeikommen würde. Das passiert nicht.
Das stimmt. Andererseits ist natürlich auch Deutschland innerhalb von Europa auch eine ziemliche Hochburg. Speziell für Linux und Open Source im Allgemeinen.
Definitiv. In absoluten Zahlen bestimmt. In Relativ-Zahlen aber nicht. Da ist Finnland ja immer schon absolut dominierend. Insofern stehen die Amerikaner relativ auch nicht so gut da.
Hast du da eine Erklärung dafür, warum das so ist?
Die Dunkelheit in Finnland, glaube ich, die Hälfte des Jahres ist dunkel. Was soll man anderes machen als der Computerei?
Gut, ich meine, da könnte man dann auch mit Schweden und Norwegen gucken.
Aber ich fand das immer interessant, wenn man auf Konferenzen geht, sich anzugucken, was für Leute da überhaupt auftauchen. Weil es sind auf den verschiedenen Konferenzen auf der Welt ganz verschiedene Leute. Und man kann schon feststellen, dass irgendwie weiße Männer, die schon in der zweiten Generation reich sind oder so was, definitiv dominierend sind in der Open-Source-Welt. Und das hat dann irgendwie Auswüchse in alles. Das Benehmen der Leute in der Community resultiert daraus, dass sie halt doch meistens relativ privilegiert sind. Aber wenn man irgendwie mal über den Tellerrand guckt und außerhalb von Europa und USA, dann stellt man fest, dass da ist es ganz anders. Das sind Leute, die sind selbst die erste Level der Reich war oder so was, die sie überhaupt damit auseinandersetzen konnten. Und das ist was ganz anderes. Also wenn ich mich in meiner Freizeit als Kind mit Open Source auseinandergesetzt habe und als Jugendlicher, dann war das nicht weiter schwierig, weil ich hatte viel Freizeit und meine Eltern haben mir einen Computer gekauft und ich musste dann nichts irgendwie selbst, außer mein Gehirn, nichts weiter mitbringen. Außer alles andere wurde mir in die Wiege gelegt. Und das ist irgendwie bei den anderen Konferenzen etwas ganz anderes, weil das ist für die Leute dann irgendwie was, wo sie sich das erkämpft haben. Und dann haben sie erstmal irgendwie der Job in der Software, der ist primär erstmal was um Geld zu kriegen. Und sekundär ist dann freie Software ganz toll, während irgendwie die Prioritäten ja alle ganz anders sind für viele von den freien Software-Leuten in Europa und in Amerika, weil es halt nicht so direkt wichtig ist, irgendwie Geld zu verdienen. Und es ist viel wichtiger, irgendwie für viele von uns freie Software zu machen. Und alles andere steht denen hinteran. Also nicht, dass alle jetzt so werden, aber es ist schon irgendwie eine andere Priorität. Und sind da möglich, die irgendwie bei anderen Gegenden nicht so möglich sind.
Wann bist du jetzt selber auf die Computer gekommen?
Ach, ich hatte irgendwie, als ich Kind war, als ich fünf, 14 war oder so was, haben wir von meinem Onkel einen alten Euro-PC, so einen Schneider 8088 mit DOS 3.3 und Mindest 1.0.
Also auch erst hier in Deutschland sozusagen, vorher gab es noch nichts.
Also ich hatte mal in Brasilien einen gesehen, aber, weißt du, bei Nachbarskinder hat ein Computer. Aber das war's. Ich habe ihn gesehen. Mehr habe ich nicht. Also ich bin ziemlich spät, glaube ich, eigentlich für... Also viele von meinen Mitschülern damals hatten schon einen Rechner, während ich noch keinen hatte. Aber, ja, ich fand ihn sehr spannend, muss ich zugeben. So einen tollen Euro PC 8088 mit BASIC. Also ich bin ein toller BASIC-Programmierer noch damals. Easy BASIC.
Naja, irgendwas muss ja als Einstieg herhalten.
Ja, allerdings glaube ich schon, dass BASIC so ein bisschen den Stil verdirbt, aber irgendwie hat es mir glaube ich nicht gestartet, weiß ich nicht.
Naja, ich meine, man muss ja auch erst mal was kennenlernen, damit man weiß, dass sozusagen auch Arbeit notwendig ist, um etwas zu verbessern.
Und dann? Naja, ich habe da halt immer so weiter gemacht. Dann habe ich auch noch Windows mitgemacht und alles, Windows 95 und sowas. Irgendwie hat mir ein Mitschüler mal erzählt von diesem Linux. Das sei alles frei und das konnte ich überhaupt nicht glauben. Also, dass man das einfach so kriegen konnte, ohne was zu bezahlen.
Welchem Jahr war das jetzt eigentlich?
Das müsste jetzt 1995 auch so sein oder so.
Windows 95 bis 1995.
Genau, das müsste um die selbe Zeit gewesen sein. Ich habe ja bis 1998 noch Windows benutzt. Bis Windows 98 kam irgendwie noch, das war mein letztes Windows. Aber damals, das war Slackware, was mir mein Mitschüler damals empfohlen hatte, ich soll das doch mal ausprobieren. Und dann habe ich dann mit diesen blödsinnigen Disketten dann Slackware anstellt. Ich habe nichts verstanden, ich fand es einfach nur total bescheuert.
Slackware war so eine der ersten Linux-Distributionen, die so eine gewisse Popularität erhalten haben.
Das ist schlimm, im Nachhinein ist das ganz schön crazy. Aber dann habe ich damit rumgespielt und ich habe nichts verstanden. Ich habe überhaupt nicht verstanden, was soll das? Also warum machen sich die Leute, die müde damit mit Kommandozahlen rumarbeiten, wenn es auch mit Windows 95 oder sowas oder 98 oder was auch immer grafisch ging, habe ich überhaupt nicht kapiert. Dann habe ich es irgendwie ganz schnell wieder gehört, so nach einem Monat oder sowas und festgestellt, okay, Linux ist nichts für mich. Und es ist dann aber nicht so geblieben. Irgendwann habe ich dann mit einem anderen Mitschüler mir zusammen Red Hat 5.0 gekauft und das war dann auf CD schon. Das war schon alles ein bisschen weiter und dann habe ich es installiert. Seitdem war Linux eigentlich immer auf meinem Rechner. Da habe ich dann auch erst mal was verstanden. Da gab es ein Handbuch dazu und es gab was Grafisches irgendwie, FVWM damals, schreckliches Ding, aber hat funktioniert. Dann hat man immer mehr verstanden und hat es eigentlich mehr losgelassen. Seit Windows 98 oder so etwas Ähnliches habe ich kein Windows mehr angerührt.
Das heißt, was dir eigentlich gereizt hat, war der Zugriff, den man auf einmal hatte?
Ja, definitiv hat man gemerkt, dass war nicht diese Black Box, die man akzeptieren musste, sondern man konnte die Quellen runterladen. Am Anfang konnte ich kein zählen. Ich habe das alles nicht verstanden, was ich da überhaupt getan habe, aber man konnte es alles halt selbst bauen. Und man hat dann irgendwie Stück für Stück sich das alles so erarbeitet und herausgekriegt, wie das alles funktioniert, wie C-Programm wirklich funktioniert und wie Make und dieser ganzen Kram funktioniert. Der ist ja auch manchmal wahnsinnig komplex und unsinnigerweise komplex, also viel komplexer als es notwendig ist. Wenn man sich damals sowas mit Autocon von Automake auseinandergesetzt hat, dann hat man nur irgendwie, also ehrlich gesagt... Ja, ehrlich gesagt, heutzutage, wenn man sich das anguckt, kann man auch nur noch mit den Augen rollen, dass wir das immer noch benutzen und es immer noch das Beste ist. Es ist ganz schön traurig, aber es ist schon ganz schön schlimm.
Ja, UNIX ist wirklich gelebte Computerhistorie. Das ist wahr.
Irgendjemand sollte das mal korrigieren, dass die Leute nicht mehr Autocon von Automake benutzen, weil es ist schon schlimm.
Ich weiß noch die Zeit, da gab es kein Autocon von kein Automake. Ich sagte dir, was da erforderlich war, das war noch viel schlimmer.
Ja, es gibt viel schlimmeres damals. Wir benutzen ja irgendwie ein System, dem benutzt man ja auch Autocon von Automake. Schlicht und einfach ist das das Einzige, was alles kann, weil es funktioniert. Aber man wundert sich schon trotzdem, warum Leute sich das antun. Das muss man sich schon mal vorstellen, dass Autocon von Automake, da wird eine Poemiersprache durch eine andere Poemiersprache generiert, die dann eine dritte Poemiersprache generiert. Das ist irgendwie Perlcode, der ein Shell-Script generiert, der anschließend irgendwann mal eine Make-Data generiert. Wer denkt sich so einen Unsinn aus, wie diese ganzen... Nee, das ist sogar noch kompliziert. Das ist ein Perl-Script, was ein M4-Script generiert, was ein Shell-Script generiert, was ein Make-File generiert.
Auch nur ein Skript, was wiederum andere Programme generiert.
Genau, das geht sogar noch eine Stufe weiter. Aber wer überlegt sich so was? Wir halten das auch noch für normal unter UNIX. Das ist schon ein bisschen traurig.
Ich glaube, die Wahrheit ist, das hat sich keiner überlegt, sondern das hat sich einfach so entwickelt.
Irgendjemand muss das mal aufräumen, aber ich bin das nicht. Aber es geht ja eigentlich nicht so.
Ja, das Aufräumen, das ist dann so ein bisschen dein Thema gewesen, habe ich so den Eindruck gehabt. Ich weiß nicht, wann fing das so an? Du hast dann irgendwann angefangen, auch komplette Projekte unter Linux zu starten?
Ja, irgendwie gab es immer so ein paar Dinge, die mich interessiert haben damals. Das erste war, ESD war so ein Sound-Server, der kam von Enlightenment und wurde von GNOME benutzt. Er hat Audio gemixt. Da dachte ich, okay, da kann ich aber was besser, dachte ich. Dann dachte ich, das schreibe ich doch mal über ein Wochenende. Dann habe ich das über ein Wochenende geschrieben, und dann war es scheiße. Wie die Dinge halt so gehen, war es mehr als ein Wochenende. Das war dann irgendwann Pulse Audio. Das war ganz schön viel Arbeit. Es ist ja auch immer noch sehr erfolgreich, aber heutzutage arbeite ich nicht mehr selber dran.
Was macht Pulse Audio insgesamt?
Pulse Audio ist ein Consumer Audio Stack. Das erste Level ist, dass er nur Audio mixt. Es ist mehr so ein Application-Server, mit dem man lauter verschiedene Dinge machen kann. Ich habe vorhin hier noch offline mit dir auch besprochen, wie man Soundkarten zusammenfassen kann, dass du mehrere Soundkarten hast und die Synchronen nur noch eine sind. Solche Dinge kann man machen. Es kann Filter applizieren, so Echo-Cancellation und so. Es hat den ganzen Hotplug-Kram drin, den ganzen Bluetooth-Kram drin, dass man Bluetooth-Audio machen kann und so was. Das heißt, es kann irgendwie so Streams live während sie gehen von einem Device aufs nächste schieben. Es kann Lautstärke anpassen, wenn die Hardware das nicht kann. Oder wenn die Hardware eine ungenaue Lautstärkeanpassung hat, kannst du in den Software noch mehr machen, kann irgendwie alle möglichen Effekte haben, kannst du reinladen. Hier ist so ein Filterkram, dass du irgendwie bessere Höhentonen weggenommen kannst. Und es ist alles insgesamt relativ kompliziert. Aber es war sehr spannend damals irgendwie. Aber der Fokus ist ganz klar immer dabei gewesen auf Consumer-Kram. Also das heißt, dass man, damit hätte man nie pro Audio Hardware gebaut. Das war nie der Fokus und es war explizit auch dagegen designt, weil das, woran Pulse Audio, was es richtig gut konnte, oder auch immer noch kann, ist so eine Logik, dass man immer die Latenz angepasst hat an dem, was die Programme gerade benötigen. Weil es gibt halt immer diesen Deal, wenn du Telefonie machen willst oder wenn du Audioproduktion machen willst, brauchst du eine relativ niedrige Latenz. Wenn du eine Musik abspielst, reicht eine sehr hohe Latenz. Aber der Energieverbrauch ist immer im Gegensatz zu der Latenz. Wenn du eine lange Latenz hast, ist der Energieverbrauch niedrig, weil die Maschine nur relativ selten aufwachen muss, um neue Daten an die Soundkarte zu geben. Wenn du niedrige Latenzen haben willst, musst du unterbrochen aufwachen, um diesen kurzen Plaffer immer wieder vollzufüllen. Bei Pro-Audio ist das komplett irrelevant. Dann interessierst du dich nicht für Energiesparen. Dann hast du ganz andere Probleme.
Hauptsache niedrige Latenz, Hauptsache gute Performance.
Aber für alles andere, für so Consumer Hardware, wenn du ein Handy baust oder so, oder irgendwas anderes, kommt es immer darauf an, dass du wenig häufig aufwachst. Was ein paar Säule die komplexität war, und auch immer noch ist, ist, dass wir da drin dynamisch die Latenz anpassen können. Das heißt, je nachdem, was gerade irgendwie die kürzeste Latenz, die irgendein Programm requestet hat, ist, die die gilt. Und dann passen alle immer dynamisch ihre Blockgrößen an. Das, was Pausodio macht. Und noch viel mehr.
Audio ist ja eigentlich wirklich eine der widerlichsten Sachen, die man auf dem Computer überhaupt implementieren kann, weil...
Ich fand's total spannend.
Nee, widerlich nicht im Sinne von, dass es keine Herausforderungen hat. Es hat einfach extrem hohe Herausforderungen, weil wenn es irgendwo reißt, knackt's. Dann ist es sozusagen sofort unangenehm. So ein Ruckler im Bild, das nimmt man mal so mit, wenn es kurz mal flackert, da fängt nicht jeder an zu schreien. Aber Audio darf halt nie knacken. Ich rede hier aus Erfahrung.
Ja, aber ich fand auch, viel davon ist irgendwie übertrieben. Also zum Beispiel Pausodio habe ich ganz viel Zeit darin investiert, irgendwie so Lock-Free-Synchronisierung einzubauen. Also Lock-Free ist so... Es ist halt, dass man eben keine Locks nimmt, irgendwie so ganz Low-Level-Kram, die Art der Programmierung. Und so im Nachhinein irgendwie... Ich habe das gemacht, weil alle das gemacht haben, die Audio gemacht haben und alle ganz stolz drauf waren, Jack zum Beispiel und sowas. Aber im Nachhinein sage ich mir, was soll der Unfug? Das ist überhaupt nicht notwendig. Die Prozessoren sind so schnell und solange deine Locks, die du nimmst, nur kurz genommen werden, ist das alles gar kein Problem. Was hinterher zu dem Ergebnis geführt hat, ist der Unsinn davon, dass sowieso die Treiber 1.000 Locks nehmen und wenn dein Pulse-Audio, was über den Treiber liegt, so sorgfältig ist, ist es pepegal, wenn der Treiber hinter sowieso die Locks nimmt. Jemand hat mir neulich erzählt, dass die neue Version von Ada, also diese Aufnahmesoftware für Linux, dass die inzwischen sogar Pulse-Audio per default nimmt. Eigentlich reicht Pulse-Audio sogar für den Po-Audiogramm. Weil wir halt die Latenz anpassen können. Wir sind natürlich nicht optimiert darauf, dass die Latenz ultra kurz ist, weil das nie in unserem Fokus war. Aber anscheinend reicht das aus. Und das alles, was ich daraus verstanden habe, ist, okay, man kann da wahnsinnig viel machen. Und man kann sich wahnsinnig viele komplexe Probleme machen. Aber sind sie tatsächlich irgendwie alle notwendig, bin ich gar nicht mal so sicher. Vieles ist da einfacher, wenn man mal ein bisschen pragmatisch wäre. Oder jetzt sieht man zum Beispiel einen G-Streamer. Also für Leute, die es nicht kennen, G-Streamer ist so ein Framework, mit dem man Videos abspielen kann, Musik abspielen kann, mit dem man so Pipelines zusammensetzen kann mit Codex und so weiter. Und was halt kompliziert daran ist, ist, wenn man so Audio und Video abspielt, dann muss das synchron sein. Also das Lip-Synchron ist irgendwie, wenn jemand auf dem Video-Bildschirm den Mund öffnet, dass dann auch gleich zählter Ton dazu kommt. Und deswegen braucht man so eine komplizierte Synchronisierung. Das heißt, man muss immer genau wissen, welcher Frame ist gerade auf dem Bildschirm angekommen und welche Samples muss man dann so und so viel Millisekunden vorher an die Soundkarte gegeben haben, dass auch die Soundkarte gerade an dieser Stelle ist. Das ist extrem komplex. Und die meisten Media-Frameworks, die geben sich wahnsinnig Mühe, das hinzukriegen, indem sie das alles selber schedulen. Also das heißt, die überlegen sich, okay, die Soundkarte ist jetzt so weit, der Bildschirm ist jetzt so weit, dann schedulen wir jetzt mal das nächste, was wir auf dem Bildschirm bringen müssen, nach der Soundcard-Clock. Die Leute von G-Streamer, die haben das alles gemacht und hatten immer früher so verschiedene Schedule da drin. Das ist diese ganze Komplexität. Aber letztendlich, irgendwie, im G-Streamer 1.0 oder so was, oder 0.8 oder so was, haben die Entwickler gesagt, okay, das ist viel zu kompliziert, das versteht keiner mehr, wir schmeißen das alles raus. Und anstatt, dass irgendwie G-Streamer das selber schedulet, läuft das jetzt einfach als individuelle Shreds, jeder Teil, und der Körner schedulet das. Das Körner hat natürlich nie Ahnung, was jetzt irgendwie gerade auf den Bildschirm gebracht werden muss. Welcher von den Shreds jetzt zuerst ausgeführt wird, wenn mehrere lauffähig sind, das ist nicht definiert. Da sucht der Körner sich irgendwas aus nach irgendwelchen guten Algorithmen, die er sich mal überlegt hat, aber der hat natürlich keine Ahnung, was wirklich irgendwie wichtig ist. Und das funktioniert. Man kann sich das alles kompliziert machen, das kann er ja selber programmieren, weil man dem Betriebssystem Körner nicht traut. Aber effektiv, für fast alle Fälle reicht das komplett aus, sich nicht so ein Wust zu machen, sondern einfach Locking zu benutzen, Stratting zu benutzen und den Körnern eine ganze Menge zu lösen lassen. Weil die haben ähnliche Probleme schon gelöst. Das ist dann natürlich nicht so optimiert, aber die Optimierung ist gar nicht notwendig. Meistens muss es gar nicht so kompliziert sein, der ganze Audiokram, glaube ich, wie ich mir das damals gemacht habe und wie die Leute sich das immer noch machen heutzutage.
Das ist immer ganz interessant, weil ich glaube, das sagt auch eine ganze Menge über diese Dynamiken in der Entwicklung bei Linux oder Source-Welt allgemein aus. Es gibt ja nicht nur ein Audio-Framework oder ein Audio-Video-Framework, sondern es gibt mindestens, keine Ahnung, drei, vier, fünf verschiedene Ansätze, mehr oder weniger erfolgreich, die teilweise dasselbe, teilweise nur etwas ähnliches auf einer anderen Ebene versucht haben zu lösen. Vollkommen unabhängig voneinander entwickelte Ansätze, um ein Problem zu lösen, wo dann eben man in der Nutzerseite natürlich immer das Problem hat, ok, jetzt habe ich die Software, die setzt auf dieses Subsystem und die Software würde ich auch gerne benutzen, die setzt aber auf dieses Subsystem und die können aber beide nicht gleichzeitig irgendwie so richtig oder zumindest nicht so ohne weiteres, wie man das in dem Moment braucht. Und dann schüttelt man natürlich schnell so mit dem Kopf und denkt sich so, gibt es denn hier irgendwie keine Koordinierung. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch so ein bisschen Survival of the fittest. Also es hat sozusagen auch den Raum, dass alle Dinge auch mal komplett von A bis Z durchgespielt werden und wenn es dann halt am Ende scheitert, dann hat man es zumindest probiert. Ist da was dran?
Ja, ich glaube aber auch, dass es irgendwie gar nicht so divers ist, wie das tatsächlich erscheint auf den ersten Blick, weil irgendwie, wenn man sich anguckt, was Firmen tatsächlich bauen hinterher aus dem ganzen Kram, dann ist es schon so irgendwie, also die meisten Leute würden G-Streamer und M-Player oder sowas für Videoplayer halten und VLC und sowas. Und VLC ist sicherlich der populärste heutzutage, den selbst irgendwie die Windows-Leute alle benutzen. Aber Firmen bauen Produkte fast ausschließlich auf G-Streamer, weil G-Streamer ist irgendwie, das kann eben alles und du kannst generische Pipelines damit ausdrücken. Und es hat halt diesen großen Sprung, dass es irgendwie wirklich generisch ist und ein API ist und ein Framework ist, was versucht, das ganze Problem zu erschlagen. Und im Gegensatz dazu sind M-Player und solche immer alle sehr spezifisch. Die haben eine Playback-Pipeline, Ende der Geschichte. Die kann zwar relativ kompliziert werden, aber es ist immer noch eine Playback-Pipeline. Man gibt es ein paar relatable Projekte zu M-Player, die noch was anderes machen, aber letztendlich, das hat nicht diesen Anspruch, komplett generisch zu sein. Das ist bei Pulse Audio genau das Gleiche gewesen. Es gab natürlich ganz viele andere Frameworks, aber letztendlich alle, die jemals was Professionelles daraus, also ein Produkt daraus gebaut haben, haben Pulse Audio genommen. Nokia zum Beispiel, eine Telefone. Das ist alles irgendwie inzwischen der Vergangenheit, weil niemand mehr Linux-Telefone baut tatsächlich. Aber alle, die irgendwie so richtig auf die freie Software Art und Weise irgendwas daraus gebaut haben, die haben Pulse Audio genommen, weil irgendwie der ganze Logik mit dem Consumer-Audio, dass du da irgendwie Latenzen anpassen willst, das kann dann tatsächlich keiner. Das heißt, du kannst irgendwie, wenn du von 100.000 Metern Höhe oder sowas auf den ganzen Kram guckst, glaubt man, dass Jack und Pulse Audio und wie sie alle heißen und ESD alles das selber machen. Und das tun sie dann auch irgendwie. Aber letztendlich Produkte drauf bauen, willst du nicht aus. Du willst niemals ein Consumer-Produkt aus Jack bauen. Das wäre komplett irrsinnig, weil dann würdest du so viel CPU verbrennen, wie es nur geht, weil er alles in Freescommern macht, alles mit minimalen Latenzen. Das will man ja nicht. Und du würdest auch nicht ESD benutzen, weil ESD viel zu unflexibel ist. Das heißt, irgendwie ist es halt nicht ein Wunder, dass letztendlich dann diese ganzen Consumer-Dinger dann doch irgendwie Pulse Audio genommen haben. Aber es kommt natürlich immer darauf an, was man wirklich genau baut. Aber irgendwie der Unterschied zwischen Pulse Audio und den anderen ist, dass das halt irgendwie generisch ist. Sehr, sehr generisch ist.
Worauf ich aber eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, es hat sich nicht ein großer Multimedia-Framework-Ansatz durchgesetzt bis heute.
Ja, kommt drauf an. Produkte, wie gesagt, bauen heutzutage fast alles immer aus Gstreamer, wenn sie was machen.
Ja gut, aber man muss sozusagen diese Entscheidung noch selber fällen. Welches Subsystem nehme ich denn jetzt? Es ist nicht so, dass es so das, klar, Audio, Video, Linux läuft so. Es hätte ja auch sein können, dass sowas sich entwickelt.
Ehrlich gesagt glaube ich schon, dass es so funktioniert. Wie gesagt, es kommt darauf an, was man sich anguckt. Als End-User hat man eine viel größere Auswahl. Weil die Leute, die VLC und M-Player benutzen, das sind primär Leute, die das Scratch Your Own Edge, also das heißt Leute, die selber Videos gerne gucken möchten am Rechner. Und dafür ist es dann auch total tolle Software. Aber da hat man die Wahl, welchen Videoplayer man benutzt. Aber wenn du ein Produkt bauen willst, was mehr kann als nur VLC starten, dann ist das alles ganz anders. Weil dann sagst du, ich brauche etwas Generisches, was ich programmieren kann, wo ich alles Mögliche anschließen kann und noch das und jenes und so einen Codec einplacken kann. Und dann nicht nur was abspielen kann, sondern auch noch einen Filter applizieren oder das durch das und das durchpacken. Und das kannst du eben dann alles nur mit streamen. Also es kommt drauf an. Ich glaube, das ist viel unifizierter, als man denken könnte, sobald man den ganz trivialen Use-Case verlässt. Und der triviale Use-Case ist halt irgendwie einfach nur eine DVD abspielen oder so, ein AV abspielen.
Dich hat es dann nicht ewig bei dem Pulse-Audio gehalten, sondern du hast dann das Avahi-Projekt gestartet, das ja so ein bisschen inspiriert ist von der Apple Vorarbeit.
Also der Hintergrund war der, ich wollte den Pulse-Audio einbauen, so eine Logik, dass man Netzwerk-Audio hatte und dass sich die Instanzen von Pulse-Audio automatisch selber finden würden. Also Service Discovery. Und dann habe ich damals rumgespielt und damals gab es eine, also das einzige Service Discovery, was irgendwie die Leute tatsächlich wirklich benutzt haben, war von Apple, damals hieß das Rendezvous, heutzutage heißt das Bonjour. Und da hatte jemand einen Port gemacht zu Linux und das hier hieß Howl. Und es war so lizenzrechtlich äußerst problematisch, weil der hat so zwei Lizenzen gemixt, ich weiß nicht mehr die Details, aber die man nicht hätte mixen dürfen, deswegen haben irgendwie kaum Distros das aufgenommen. Dann habe ich halt irgendwie Pass Audio darauf portiert, also den Supporter hat damit geschrieben, und es ging alles ganz toll, aber die Distros haben es alle nicht aufgenommen, weil die Lizenz irgendwie widersinnig war. Und dann hat er gesagt, okay, schreibe ich doch mal in einem Wochenende neu. Das war dann auch mal wieder ein bisschen länger als ein Wochenende. Aber das war eigentlich wirklich sehr spannend, weil Apple hat da wirklich tolles Design geliefert. Also irgendwie UPnP.
Das heißt das Stack und Play von...
Genau, das hat Microsoft und Intel zusammen gemacht. Und das ist so ein kompletter Horror. Das ist irgendwie so HTTP auf UDP zum Multicasten mit XML. Das ist irgendwie so eine Checkliste von allem, was irgendwie crazy ist, haben die gemacht. Und deswegen funktioniert der meiste UPnP-Kram auch lange Jahre nicht. Heutzutage funktioniert er auf der meisten Hardware, aber das hat lange gebraucht. Und selbst wenn man sich das heute noch anguckt, denkt man immer nur, um Gottes Willen, was haben die Leute sich überlegt? Das ganze Gegenteil war das, was Apple sich da überlegt hat. Die hatten also richtig gute Engineering. Die haben sich hingesetzt, haben irgendwie angeguckt, was gibt es schon irgendwie, worauf könnte es basieren? Haben das dann auf DNS basiert? Also richtig low-level simple Protokolle, die jeder kann, haben die einfach erweitert für Multicasting, sodass man irgendwie so eine DNS-Zone hatte, die halt keinen Server braucht, sondern sich irgendwie selbst im Netzwerk organisiert.
Also man hatte sozusagen das Prinzip von DNS, also Namen und Adressen zuordnen, nachgebaut, ohne dass man einen Server braucht, sondern halt im Netz untereinander dynamisch.
Genau, und die haben es eben mit der richtigen Technik irgendwie genommen, weil irgendwie du willst nicht den komplizierten XML-Wahnsinn haben für sowas, sondern es reicht komplett aus, wenn man einfach die DNS-Konzepte, die alle Leute kennen, die einfach sind, einfach wieder benutzt. Und das war richtig gutes Engineering. Und die haben sich außerdem noch überlegt, also wahnsinnig viel Sorgfalt da reingesteckt, dass sie immer so Traffic Suppression gemacht haben. Weil irgendwie, wenn du 500 Rechner hast im Netzwerk, im lokalen Land, die alle immer broadcasten, hier bin ich und ich habe hier so Dienste, das skaliert natürlich nicht. Dann ist dein Netzwerk sofort irgendwie verstopft und das war's. Das heißt, die haben sich sehr viel Mühe damit gegeben, das zum Skalieren zu kriegen, sodass die Leute immer, es geht an mit Oberflächlichkeiten, wie was weiß ich, dass die nicht ununterbrochen das announced haben, sondern exponentiell das gewechselt haben. Aber es ging noch weiter, dass die halt immer unterdrückt haben, wenn jemand anderes schon was gesagt hatte, was übereinstimmte mit dem, was sie selber announce wollten, dann haben sie es selber nicht mehr announced. Das macht es alles sehr viel skalierender, als es irgendwie sein könnte. Es skaliert natürlich immerhin nicht zu 100.000 Rechnern, im lokalen Netzwerk, aber wer macht das sowas auch? Aber es war richtig gutes Engineering und da dachte ich, okay, das implementiere ich. Und dann hat es ein bisschen länger gedauert, weil diese ganzen Traffic Suppression-Kram, der ist dann doch irgendwann mal ein bisschen kompliziert und aufwendig. Insbesondere, weil das alles irgendwie so Network-Facing ist, dann musst du immer richtig aufpassen, was du da eigentlich tust, weil irgendwie sonst die Leute das zum Einbrechen benutzen und sowas. Und ja, das war Avahi. War total genial, irgendwie, sich mit Netzwerk auseinandersetzen zu können und jemand heute sowas bauen. Und sogar die Leute von Apple fanden das gut. Irgendwie einer von denen, Cheshire oder sowas, hat mal einen Talk bei Google gehalten und hat mal gesagt, ja, die Avahi-Avahia-Implementation ist besser als unsere eigene. Wenn die das so zugeben. Und gerade was ganz lustig ist, ist gerade irgendwie ein System, dem kommen wir gerade bei diesem selben Thema wieder an. Und weil wir bauen da so einen DNS-Resolver rein, oder haben wir auch schon eingebaut. Aber irgendwie, ich will jetzt den Kram so verheiraten, dass Multicast-DNS, also dieses Protokoll, was er einfach sich überlegt hat, nur noch ein Teil von einem normalen DNS-Dac ist. Das heißt, dass Avahi dann nicht irgendwas ist, was man installiert, sondern das macht einfach der ganz normale DNS-Dac.
Das gehört halt einfach dazu.
Genau, weil das ist. Ja, das gehört aber. Selbst Windows baut das ja inzwischen bei sich ein. Also irgendwie, Windows hat ja immer ein inkompatibles Protokoll, was es selber gemacht hat, also teilweise selber gemacht hat, erfunden, nämlich LLMNR. Das geht um Namensauflösung und dann UPnP on top für die ganzen Service Discovery. UPnP ist wie gesagt schrecklich, aber dieser LLMNR-Teil, der ist von Windows immer supported gewesen und der MDS-Teil immer von Apple supported gewesen, aber die konnten sich nicht gegenseitig finden. Mit dem einen konntest du irgendwie einen Rechner im lokalen Netz, der Foo hieß, ganz einfach Ping Foo schreiben. Das war bei Windows. Bei Mac musst du hinschreiben pingfoo.local. Aber low-level waren das fast die gleichen Konzepte. Also da hat Microsoft für diesen Namensauflösungsteil, nicht für die Service Discovery-Teil, aber für den Namensauflösungsteil, haben sie sich das sozusagen das Apple-Protokoll angeguckt, haben den ganzen Service Discovery-Kram rausgeschmissen, haben alles, was irgendwie Traffic Suppression ist, rausgeschmissen, haben da irgendwie dieses Minimalimplementation namens LLMNR mit einer anderen Portnummer.
Link-Local-Multi-Cast-Name-Resolution.
Ganz genau. Und dann haben sie sich in irgendwelchen ITF-Diskussionsfonds immer beharkt, weil irgendwie Apple wollte halt mit MDNS und DNSSD, also diese Gesamtlösung, die halt irgendwie Service Discovery und Namensauflösung und alles zero konfiguriert da macht, standardisieren. Dagegen Microsoft wollte sagen, wir machen LLMNR für die Namensauflösung und UPnP für den ganzen Rest. Und dann haben sie sich beharkt, was zum Ergebnis sei, die haben kein Ergebnis gefunden, das ist nie ein offizieller Standard geworden, sondern immer nur so zur Ansicht. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die heißen, aber wenn ihr im EETFs oder... Ja, die haben da immer irgendwie so einen Status da oben, irgendwie informational oder sowas heißt das. Aber wir sind inzwischen so weit, dass Microsoft tatsächlich in die nächste Windows-Version jetzt endlich auch ein DNS einbaut. Weil Drucker und sowas und alle App...
In die nächste Version von 10 oder 11? Also 10 ist da jetzt gerade aufgebaut.
Was ist denn? Ich weiß leider nicht, was die aktuelle Windows-Version ist. Dann wird es wohl in 11 eingebaut.
Okay, also sie haben es noch nicht. Da ist ja auch erst 2050.
Die kam vor irgendwie einer Woche, hat jemand das geschert bei Google+. Nee, irgendwie, Windows hatte das sogar schon vorher drin sogar, aber nur für den Druckersupport. Weil viele von den Druckern kommen mit MDNS-Support. Und damit die Drucker ansteuern konnten, haben die das schon eingebaut. Aber die nächste Windows-Version baut das dann tatsächlich mal richtig ein. Aber ey, Wahnsinn, irgendwie, die, die die Köpfe einschlagen. Aber die haben irgendwie festgestellt, weil iPhones und sowas, das auch alle sprechen, dass irgendwie, weil Microsoft nicht mehr die Marktmacht hat mehr, wie sie irgendwie cloud-dominierend waren, orientieren die sich auch mal plötzlich so, was anderes zu supporten. Aber schon alleine wegen dieser ganzen Sache haben wir in unserem neuen DNS-Resolution-Kram, den wir da eingebaut haben in Systemd, der allerdings noch nicht per Default in All Distros an ist. Aber der kann halt klassisches DNS, der kann jetzt schon LLMNR, also die Microsoft-Variante, die habe ich eingebaut, weil die sofort eingebaut, weil die viel einfacher ist als MDNS, weil die ganzen Traffic Suppression, dieser ganze komplexe Kram nicht da drin ist. Und wir arbeiten gerade daran, auch jetzt MDNS einzubauen. Das heißt, dann haben wir eine einzige Lösung, die alle drei Protokolle spricht und irgendwie auch schlau ist, dabei diese Protokolle zu sprechen. Das heißt, dass der irgendwie die Anfragen an die richtige Stelle routet, je nachdem, wie es gerade sinnvoll ist.
Ich finde es ganz interessant, dass du erst Linux beiseite gelegt hast, weil da konnte man ja nicht klicken. Und sozusagen mit diesem User-Appeal eigentlich gestartet bist in die ganze Welt und dich sozusagen über diese ganzen Juckreize, die man da mit der Zeit bedient, so langsam auf den Systemlevel bis fast ganz nach unten runtergegraben hast.
Ja, irgendwie, was ich immer wichtig fand bei Linux, ich glaube, was irgendwie unsere Aufgabe ist, ist doch, dass wir alle erreichen mit Linux. Das heißt, ich glaube absolut, dass Linux einfach zu benutzen sein muss. So einfach wie möglich. Weil ich glaube schon, dass die Welt irgendwie Vorteile davon hat, wenn sie ein freies Betriebssystem hat, wo alle alles angucken können und hacken können, was einfach zu bedienen ist. Das heißt, ich war immer schon und auch insbesondere heute noch, finde ich das irgendwie, manchmal sieht man so einen Elitismus von Linux oder UNIX-Leuten, die es irgendwie toll finden, wenn sie mit ihrer Shell rumspielen und irgendwie Dinge ausdrücken können, die nicht jeder versteht. Und nicht, dass ich keine Shell benutzen würde. Also ein wahnsinnig sinnvolles, irgendwie mächtiges Tool. Aber ich sehe keinen Vorteil darin, wenn das kryptisch ist. Also was wir zum Beispiel bei Autocon von Automag diskutiert haben, das ist einfach irrsinnig kompliziert. Und ja, ich glaube, ich habe es verstanden. Aber irgendwie, ich kann schon sagen, es ist bescheuert. Also es ist komplett unsinnig. Und es gibt keinen Grund, das so kompliziert zu machen. Aber es gibt viel in der UNIX- und in der Linux-Welt Leute, die glauben, dass es irgendwie, die haben so einen Elitismus. Irgendwie, ich habe es verstanden. Und das ist gut so.
Jetzt ist das mein Geheimwissen.
Genau. Und irgendwie, meine Kumpels, die haben es auch verstanden. Das ist cool. Und mit denen kann ich mich nicht darüber unterhalten. Aber niemand anders versteht uns. Und das finde ich irgendwie, okay, Menschen sind vielleicht so. Aber ich finde es trotzdem nicht. Mein inherenter Glaube ist, dass Computer einfach sein sollten, damit wir alle Leute damit erreichen. Und das ist zum Beispiel auch ein Grund, warum ich ein großer Freund von Genome 3 bin. Die Leute haben es gehasst. Also viele Leute haben es gehasst, weil es irgendwie viel simpler war, anders war, als es vorher war. Aber wenn man das vergleicht mit dem, was vorher war, was quasi nicht komplex und unsinnig, unnötig komplex, das war, dann kann ich nur sagen, Genome 3, tollstes Ding ever. Ich bin selbst einer, der mit Genome 3 aneinandergeraten ist und irgendwie manche Dinge davon nicht mag. Aber ich muss sagen, Zielsetzung, Computer für die breite Audience einfach zu gestalten, das ist irgendwie das Wichtige. Und das ist irgendwie auch der Hintergrund, wenn man jetzt zu Systemd wieder den Sprung macht, in Systemd haben wir irgendwie Shell-Skripte sind dann doch deutlich irgendwie aus dem Fokus rausgenommen worden. Also der Bootprozess, der kommt ohne Shell aus. Und irgendwie System Control, dieser Befehl, mit dem man alles kontrolliert unter Systemd, das ist schon unser Ziel gewesen, das möglichst einfach zu machen und nicht irgendwie eine Programmiersprache da einzubauen und zu erwarten, dass der Benutzer diese Programmiersprache versteht, wie es nämlich Shell ist. Weil Shell ist eine komplizierte Programmiersprache.
Und nicht nur eine, sondern mehrere.
Ja, also wirklich eine historisch gewachsene und teilweise sehr schlimme. Ich schreibe auch die ganze Zeit Shell-Skripte, so ist es ja nicht, aber ich kann ja schon trotzdem anerkennen, dass es vielleicht nicht notwendig ist, eine Shell zu benutzen, um zu booten. Deswegen haben wir das dann so rausgenommen. Und ich glaube, es ist irgendwie eine Aufgabe von einem Software- Engineer, doch irgendwie das alles so einfach zu gestalten, dass es ihm nicht von dem Benutzer oder Admin, oder wie man ihn auch immer nennen will, der den Computer dann bedient, nicht voraussetzen kann, dass er diese Programmierungssprache kann. Und es ist natürlich immer irgendwie, viele von den Leuten, die irgendwie UNIX gelernt haben, finden das natürlich überraschend, weil die haben das gemastert und die verstehen Shell und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn wir dann kommen und sagen, okay Shell, toll, aber bitte nicht im Boot-Prozess, dann sagen die, ey, verstehe ich ja gar nichts mehr. Und natürlich haben sie da Recht, weil sie verstehen nichts mehr, weil es halt alle anders ist. Aber es ist halt schon irgendwie, System D und sowas hat halt eine Learning Curve. Und die Learning Curve ist durchaus da, wenn man vorher UNIX kannte. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, wenn man das alles zusammenrechnet, von jemandem, der keine Ahnung hat momentan, System Control zu verstehen und System D zu verstehen, ist glaube ich immer noch einfacher, als wenn man vor fünf Jahren von ihm verlangt hätte, dass er Shell lernt, dass er diesen ganzen Unfug lernt, wie Etsy aufgebaut ist mit Sysconfig und sowas. Und bei den Distros immer alles verschieden und so weiter. Insofern, wichtig ist für mich durchaus, es soll einfach sein und Service Discovery ist total toll, weil das macht die Welt einfach.
Das ist der schöne Unterschied zwischen Simple und Easy. Easy ist das, was auf dem aufbaut, was man schon weiß, auch wenn es kein leichter Weg war, da hinzukommen. Aber da man ja schon da ist, erscheint einem das einfach. Und Simple ist das einfach im Sinne von einfach, dass es eben auch mit weniger Voraussetzungen und weniger Abhängigkeiten werden kann.
Ich würde jetzt nicht behaupten, das System, die Simple wäre. Das ist schon kompliziert genug. Aber Computer sind heutzutage kompliziert. Man kann das nicht komplett machen.
Du hast ja jetzt schon ein paar Mal erwähnt. Ich möchte es noch mal kurz ein bisschen nach hinten schieben. Aber wir reden jetzt hier sozusagen auch von einem Re-Engineering des gesamten Systemen. Boot, Launch, Ablauf, Steuerungsmechanismus. Der ja so ein bisschen bei UNIX eigentlich auch ganz tief drinsteckt. Ich würde fast sogar sagen, das war eigentlich das Wesen von UNIX damals, dass es sehr viel besser geeignet war. Andere Systeme waren so, und jetzt rede ich wirklich von 70s, Minicomputer, Großcomputer, teure Rechner, die teilweise auch nur auf eine einzige Aufgabe hin entwickelt wurden oder zumindest nur für eine einzige Aufgabe eingesetzt wurden. Der Gedanke, dass Systeme für unterschiedliche Aufgaben geeignet wären oder auch nur dafür angeschafft werden würden, der war halt noch relativ fern. Besser noch, Software wurde ja dann teilweise wirklich für jeden neuen Computer komplett neu gemacht. Ein Betriebssystem wurde für jeden Computer komplett neu gemacht. Das kann man sich heutzutage überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen, aber das war die Realität. Und als UNIX kam, hatte man auf einmal so eine Tonwerkstatt, auf einmal war das alles so ein weicher Modder, wo man dann auch, wenn man das erste Mal draufschaut, vielleicht nicht so genau wusste, was man damit jetzt machen kann, aber wenn man so seine digitalen Töpfer-Fähigkeiten so ein bisschen ausgebaut hat und erstmal verstanden hat, so ah, okay, dann konnte man so Dinge zusammenstecken. Und das sind ja so Sachen, wo man heute so ein bisschen kotzt, nicht wahr? So komplizierte Shell. Das war ja damals eine Offenbarung. Also, oh, ich kann dir nicht nur Kommandos eingeben, sondern das ist auch gleich eine Programmiersprache und ich kann da Schleifen und Variablen und Flexibilitäten einbringen. Das hatte ja sozusagen seinen Merit. Das ist ja nicht so, dass das von Anfang an eine schlechte Idee war, sondern tatsächlich war es unfassbar revolutionär, wie es ja auch unfassbar revolutionär war, ein Betriebssystem in einer Hochsprache zu schreiben. Also C würde man heute nicht mehr so sehr als Hochsprache empfinden. Aber damals war das halt sozusagen der Ablöser der Maschineninstruktion, die einfach immer noch herangezogen wurden, um die ganzen Systeme zu bauen. Aber jetzt sind wir halt auch 20, 30 Jahre weiter. Und ich finde es immer wieder sehr interessant, wie auch im Prinzip ja mit dieser Linux-Revolution, die so von 1991, 1992 fing Linus Torvalds an, da auf Basis seiner Erfahrungen mit Minix und anderen Systemen das einfach mal komplett neu zu schreiben. Das hat ja eine unglaubliche Welle ausgelöst, einfach eine unglaubliche Popularität. Und quasi mal wieder so richtig bei Null anzufangen. Ist ja auch klar, dass dann auch erstmal wieder viel von dem erstmal genauso übernommen wird, wie es eben bis dahin hingeschwappt ist. Es war sehr viel mehr erstmal ein, wir brauchen das jetzt erstmal für uns, wir bauen das irgendwie nach oder wir nehmen es so wie es ist und passen es vielleicht ein bisschen an. Und das ist sozusagen die Situation, die sich jetzt zu Beginn des 21. Jahrhunderts oder sagen wir mal dieser Dekade auch noch ab 2010 so dargestellt hat, wo aber dann schon klar war, es ist eine totale Erfolgsgeschichte. Meine Linux ist gefühlt auf 99% aller Server heutzutage am Werkeln, vielleicht sind es 90, ich weiß es nicht, aber es ist einfach fast überall, weil es sich einfach gezeigt hat, dass diese Formbarkeit und diese Anpassbarkeit an alles Mögliche dort eben auch sehr lebendig weitergetragen wurde. Aber jetzt ist so ein bisschen die Zeit gekommen, wo sich das auch nochmal in die nächste Benutzbarkeitsphase entwickeln muss. Und was du meinst, um das nochmal anschließen, dieses elitistische Ausgrenzende, ich weiß auch nicht so ganz genau, wodurch das so immer befeuert würde, aber da ist schon so ein bisschen was dran, dass man so schnell auch zu so einem Weißkittel wird, der so eingeweiht sozusagen so seine Heiligtümer vor sich her trägt und dann auch so ein bisschen den Blick verliert, für wie es einem selbst eigentlich gegangen ist, als man dazu gekommen ist. Und ich finde auch ein paar Sachen auch so sozial ein bisschen bedenklich. So der User als Feind ist ja auch so ein Ding, was sich immer wieder findet in so furchtbaren Ausdrücken wie Dau und Loser und so weiter. Das ist ja, sagen wir mal, auch so eine gewisse schnippische, überhebliche Art, die für meinen Geschmack etwas kontraproduktiv ist. Hast du den Eindruck, dass sich das ändert? Hast du den Eindruck, dass es da eine Bewegung gibt? Oder ist das noch alles sehr am Anfang?
Weiß nicht. Also ich hatte irgendwie den Eindruck, als die genommen Leute damals irgendwie genau um drei gemacht haben, das alles mal irgendwie glatt gezogen haben und irgendwie ganz klar unter Designpunkten neu designt haben, ihre Oberfläche, dass da sich viel geändert hat. Aber das ist inzwischen auch eine Sache der Vergangenheit. Also ich glaube, die Leute neigen glaube ich immer zu Elitismus, weil es irgendwie einfach macht, ist oder sowas. Aber auch irgendwie mit System-D, wenn wir mal irgendwo ein Future wegnehmen, wir haben immer damit zu kämpfen, dass viele Leute das überhaupt nicht gut finden, wenn wir irgendwie ihr Favorite-Feature wegnehmen, auch wenn wir ein Problem haben, das ist niemand maintained und niemand bereit ist, da irgendwie Zeit für zu investieren. Aber ja, keine Ahnung, Menschen sind halt wie Menschen so sind. Und ich glaube, die meisten merken noch nicht mal, dass sie irgendwie dieses elitistische Gehabe haben. Aber irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich irgendwie versuche dem ja immer zu entgegen, indem ich irgendwie auf Konferenzen gehe und irgendwie versuche immer die Kommunikation mit allen Leuten irgendwie aufrechtzuhalten. Und irgendwie, ich bemühe mich auch immer irgendwie auf Konferenzen zu gehen, die nicht nur irgendwie solche elitären, irgendwie Developer-Konferenzen sind. Also, es geht sogar so weit, dass ich gerade gar nicht mehr auf Developer-Konferenzen gehe, so viel. Also, was weiß ich zum Beispiel, ich gehe auf kleinere Konferenzen in Polen und so was Ähnliches, wo meistens Leute, die irgendwie so an sowas entwickeln, gar nicht mehr hingehen. Weil irgendwie, ich glaube, es ist schon irgendwie wichtig, dass man die Verbindung zu das, was irgendwie manche Leute downen oder sowas, schon halten muss. Also, jetzt ist mein Tag, hat auch nur 24 Stunden, aber irgendwie halte ich es schon für wichtig. Man muss das ernst nehmen. Und selbst wenn ich häufig irgendwie mit den Sachen, die die Leute als Probleme haben, irgendwie, die nicht zu meinen Prioritäten erkläre, muss ich das doch wenigstens wissen, dass es die gibt. Also, irgendwie, Leute behaupten manchmal irgendwie, oder sehr häufig sogar, dass wir nicht zuhören würden in Systemd. Wir hören meistens zu, sehr genau sogar. Also zum Beispiel, ich scanne auch sogar manchmal so Reddit und solche Dinge, um herauszukriegen, was die Leute so alle denken. Oder was zumindest ein Teil der Community denkt. Aber zuhören und es dann auch zu tun, sind immer noch zwei verschiedene Dinge. Also irgendwie, mir ist das alles sehr bewusst zum Beispiel, dass es viele irgendwie alte UNIX-Leute gibt, die halt doch sehr große Probleme damit haben, das System, das alles ganz anders macht. Und das kann ich auch verstehen sogar, aber ich werde es ja trotzdem nicht ändern, weil ich glaube trotzdem, wie gesagt, irgendwie das Ziel sein muss, ein einfaches System zu erzeugen und nicht ein besonders kompliziertes.
Kommen wir nochmal zu System D, was ja jetzt sozusagen der Mittelpunkt deines derzeitigen Schaffens ist, kann man glaube ich so sagen. Das ist so 100 Prozent des Tages. Was war denn sozusagen die Analyse? Was war das Problem? Ich meine, teilweise klang es schon an. Wir haben es halt hier mit alten Infrastrukturen zu tun. Vielleicht mal so ein paar Beispiele nennen, die dich dann sozusagen überhaupt erst mal auf diesen Zug gebracht haben, so ein Projekt anzugehen. Das ist ja natürlich jetzt sozusagen die Spitzhacke am Kern.
Ich kann ein bisschen die Geschichte erzählen, wie es losging mit System D. Mit Pulser Audio und Avahi war ich immer im Low-Level-Teil des Betriebssystems zu werken. Da ist dann schon aufgefallen, dass System 5.0, so wie es war, nicht so funktioniert, wie heutzutage Rechner funktionieren. Weil heutzutage sind Rechner dynamisch. Plug and Play, du steckst eine Festplatte ein. Der ganze Bootprozess ist komplett asynchron. Das heißt, der Prozessor ist hochgefahren, der Speicher und so etwas Ähnliches, aber deswegen sind noch lange nicht die Festplatten hochgefahren. Die tauchen dann irgendwann, so wie das System bootet, dann halt poppen die irgendwie so auf. Wenn dann irgendwas aufgepoppt ist, dann kannst du ein paar Dinge aufsetzen und musst aber warten, bis was anderes auftaucht, um den nächsten Schritt zu machen. Das kann ja beliebig komplex werden, du hast Raid und so was, du musst ja auch noch so was machen. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel einen Abhängigkeitsstrang vom Boot anguckt, dann ist das ja so, der Colonel fährt hoch, der Colonel wartet auf irgendwie die FESPA, dass sie auftaucht, konfiguriert ist, dreieinweise gefunden hat und so. Das heißt auch, dass USB das enumeriert hat und irgendwie die FESPA selbst hochgefahren hat und sich gemeldet hat und so weiter und so fort. Sobald die FESPA dann aufgetaucht ist, aus der Perspektive vom Init-System, muss dann FS-Check draufgelaufen gestartet werden. Wenn FS-Check fertig ist, dann muss das gemountet werden. Und erst wenn das gemountet worden ist, kann irgendwie fortgefahren werden mit dem restlichen Teil.
Also man hat halt so Abhängigkeiten.
Man hat Abhängigkeiten und ist alles eventbasiert. Teilweise Events, die man selber kontrolliert und auslöst. Zum Beispiel startet man selber FS-Check und wartet, bis es fertig ist. Und dann löst man es aus, indem man FS-Check startet und FS-Check meldet sich wieder bei dir, wenn es fertig ist. Aber teilweise auch Events, die nicht kontrolliert werden vom Rechner, wie zum Beispiel, dass die USB-FESPA irgendwann auftaucht. Weil USB-FESPA zum Beispiel, es gibt keinerlei Regel, wie lange die brauchen, um aufzutauchen.
Sag mal kurz, was du grundsätzlich als Problem ansiehst. Weil durch diesen Boot-Prozess wollte ich eigentlich gleich noch mal so ein bisschen durchmarschieren, um das auch mal so im Detail näher zu beleuchten. Das heißt, du hast einfach gesehen, dass die alte, gewachsene Struktur den modernen Anforderungen einfach nicht mehr entspricht.
Genau, die hatte kein Konzept von Abhängigkeiten, die hatte überhaupt kein Konzept von Events. Und so funktioniert ein Rechner halt nicht mehr. Also schon lange nicht mehr, schon seit 1995 nicht mehr, wo irgendwie Microsoft in Windows 95 Plug & Play eingebaut hat. Aber System 5.0 hat dem nicht Rechnung getragen. System 5.0 hat Services gestartet und hat sich nicht dafür interessiert, ob irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten dafür galten, ob irgendwelche Events vorher eingetroffen sind, ob irgendwas eingetroffen ist. Der hat einfach die Service zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Also der Kernel wird gestartet, das System rollt sich aus und das tut es im Wesentlichen, indem es einfach eine Serie von Shell-Skripten startet, die im Dateisystem in irgendeiner Nummerierung vorliegen. Und das ist dann die Reihenfolge, mit der die Sachen gestartet werden. Ganz genau.
Und wenn die Hardware nicht aufgetaucht ist, dann ist das das Problem von dem jeweiligen Shell-Skript. Das kann dann irgendwie entweder selber darauf warten oder kann es es nicht und dann ist es racy. Und das haben auch nur irgendwie einen Teil der Shell-Skript überhaupt richtig hingekriegt, darauf zu warten. Und wenn irgendjemand auf irgendwas gewartet hat, dann hat alles, was danach gestartet worden ist, musst du darauf warten, dass das auch fertig wird.
Also etwa dauert es ewig lange oder es failt und kann danach nicht wieder gestartet werden, all diese ganzen Probleme?
Und alles wird irgendwie, alles ist von einem irgendwie plötzlich abhängig. Und eigentlich will man das ganze Problem auseinanderreißen und nur genau das starten, wenn der Event eingetreten ist, der dafür sorgt, dass es gestartet werden kann. Und man will alles irgendwie als Einheit sehen, als einzelne Einheiten sehen, wo du irgendwie deinen Abhängigkeitsbaum hast und alles, wenn irgendwas oben failt, dann sollen nur die Kinder davon failen und nicht irgendwie alles. Auf jeden Fall, wir haben das so gesehen und dachten, okay, da muss man irgendwas machen. Und dann... Wann war das? Also System.ly selbst ist jetzt ja schon 5 Jahre alt oder so was Ähnliches. Und da hatte ich mich damals hingesetzt und habe mal was angefangen, das hieß Babykid. Irgendwie damals haben wir irgendwie, meine Kollegen und ich, die alle immer so in diesem Low-Level-Teil vom Betriebssystem gearbeitet haben, haben wir immer alles Kit genannt. Also irgendwie gab es Policy-Kit und Device-Kit und was weiß ich noch alles. Und deswegen gab es dann auch Baby-Kit, weil das ging nämlich darum, dass es babysitten sollte, Prozesse, also Service ist babysitten. Und dieses Projekt hatte ich dann angefangen und hatte mal ein bisschen rumgeschrieben oder so was Ähnliches. Es war mal wieder so ein, schreibe ich an ein Wochenende-Projekt. Also nee, es war es nicht. Es war mir schon klar, dass es nicht ein Wochenende sein würde. Aber zu dem gleichen Zeitpunkt hat dann James Scott Remnant Upstart gepusht. Und Upstart erschien uns auf den ersten Blick genau das zu sein, was wir wollten. Weil es hat den ganzen System-Python-Logik weggelassen, dass es irgendwie den Boot linear hochbooted. Also man hat alles strictly event-based gemacht. Also das heißt, immer musste irgendwie die Festbade erst auftauchen. Und das war der Auslöser, der FS-Check lief. Und wenn der FS-Check dann wieder gesagt hat, dass es jetzt fertig ist, dann wurde es gemountet. Und wenn das alles fertig gemountet worden ist, dann wurde mit dem Boot fortgefahren. Und das war total toll, weil es ist irgendwie ganz anders als alles vorher. Und alles so wie eigentlich Rechner heutzutage funktionieren. Außerdem war der Quelltext exzellent. Das System 5 in it ist immer noch ein furchtbarer Quelltext. Also der ist über Geschichte gewachsen und alle Leute haben da irgendwie so, also von Oberflächlichkeiten, dass der Coding-Style horrible ist. Der Coder war wirklich schlimm. Und an manchen Stellen einfach nur wahnsinnig unsinnig. System 5 in it hat ja irgendwie so die Konzepte von Run-Levels. Man fragt sich immer noch, was haben die sich dabei gedacht, sieben Run-Levels zu finden, die von 0 bis 6 durchnummeriert sind, wo die immer irgendwie eine Bedeutung haben. Und es kann genau ein Buchstabe sein, du kannst genau 6 haben davon. Das sind alles so widersinnige Ideen. Du hast vielleicht was 1970er-designed, aber das ist nicht mehr wie man heutzutage irgendwie...
Ja, das war ja noch so, ich erinnere mich noch, das war ja im Prinzip die Unterscheidung zwischen, du hast jetzt nur deinen Kernel hochgefahren, um so niedrige Tätigkeiten zu machen, und dann so, das ist hier so dein Grundset, und jetzt gibt es auch Netzwerk, und jetzt läuft da auch was drauf. Und weiter hat man da irgendwie nicht gedacht. Also eigentlich wollte man nur wirklich auf vier, fünf, also da war schon, sagen wir mal, das Unterscheiden von sechs verschiedenen Zuständen, war schon weit gedacht, weil man eigentlich nur drei bestenfalls unterschieden hat.
Aber das Schöne war ja, dass auch noch zwei von den Zuständen, die noch keine Zustände waren, das waren nämlich Reboot und Power auf Node und 6 oder so ähnlich. Aber wir haben ja, das war irgendwie, schien uns alles widersinnig, was vorher da war, in vielerlei Hinsicht. Und dann kam Upstart, und Upstart war irgendwie total toll. Und dann habe ich Babykid gesagt, okay, cool, muss ich nicht lösen, macht das zu God Remnant. Und der Code war genial, also wirklich extrem sorgfältiger. Code hatte Unitests für alle, tolle Kommentare, war wunderbar. Nur ist es da leider nicht so weiter gegangen. Irgendwie, Scott Remnant hat das für Canonical gemacht, aber in seiner Freizeit irgendwie, das war nicht sein Hauptprojekt. Und deswegen hat sich Upstart eigentlich nicht mehr bewegt. Das kam dann plötzlich so auf die Szene. Und es ging so weit, dass Red Hat bei RHEL 6 das auch reingenommen hat. Aber selbst Red Hat hat das nicht wirklich benutzt mit dem Event-Based-Kram, sondern hat das eigentlich nur als Reimplementation von dem alten Kram, weil Upstart eine gewisse Kompatibilität da hatte, benutzt. Das war es irgendwie nicht werden. Und uns ist irgendwann klar geworden, dass dieses Konzept, das Upstart implementiert, unvollständig ist. Und zwar fundamental. Und zwar das, was wir uns überlegt haben, ist, dass wenn man ein System hochfährt, dann muss man wissen, wo man hin will. Also man muss sich überlegen, Festplatten müssen eingesteckt sein, dieser Dämmen muss gestartet sein und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn man dann bestimmt, was man beim Buden alles macht, dann muss man sich das angucken, wo man hin will, und daraus berechnen, was man denn überhaupt jetzt alles insgesamt starten will. Weil irgendwie auf die Festplatte zu warten, muss man nur, wenn man da auf dem FS-Check starten will, und wenn man aufs FS-Check wartet, dann braucht man das auch nur, wenn man das mounten will tatsächlich. Und das mounten braucht man auch nur, wenn man tatsächlich den Dämmen starten hinterher will, der irgendwie auf das Totalsystem zugreift. Das heißt, dieses Abhängigkeitssystem, das muss genutzt werden, um irgendwie zu bestimmen, was du hinter Buden willst, damit minimiert werden kann, was getan werden kann, was getan wird während des Boot-Prozesses. Das heißt, man überlegt sich irgendwie, wo will man hin, und dann berechnet man aus dem Abhängigkeitsbaum den minimalen Satz von UNIX, wie wir das genannt haben, die gestartet werden müssen. Upstart hat das aber nie gemacht. Upstart, da hatte es der Admin oder Developer, hatte die Aufgabe, die Events miteinander zu verknüpfen. Das heißt, man hat in Upstart irgendwie hingeschrieben, okay, wenn das passiert ist, macht das. Wenn das passiert ist, macht das. Das heißt, in Upstart war nie eine Logik drin, wie das dahinten will ich hin, berechne mir die Schritte vorher, sondern es war sozusagen der Admin, der diese Schritte selbst berechnet hat auf dem Blatt Papier oder wo auch immer im Kopf und es reingeschrieben hat, dass das jeweils passieren müsste. Da ist da wieder der weiße Kittel. Ich glaube, er hat das nicht so gemeint.
Ja, aber letztlich, man braucht halt wieder Systemwissen.
Ich finde das ja noch nicht, ja, ja. Ich finde es noch nicht mal unattraktiv, was er da gemacht hat, weil das System war extrem simpel. Weil er hat einfach gesagt, mach das, wenn das passiert. Es war so ein Regel-Executor, total toll. Während das, was wir als Systemliner letztendlich gemacht haben, dass wir so einen Abhängigkeitsresolver haben, ist wahnsinnig komplex. Das ist Grafenteori. Da hast du deinen komischen Abhängigkeitsbaum und dann versuchst du irgendwie den Kern zu finden von dem Kram, den du brauchst. Und dann testest du, dass das zyklenfrei ist und was weiß ich noch alles. Das hat er sich alles um drum gedrückt. Brauche er ja nicht, wenn das einfach der Admin ist, der das hinschreibt. Insofern, irgendwann ist uns das klar geworden. Das greift zu kurz. Effektiv hat es immer zum Ergebnis gehabt, dass es maximal viel gestartet hat. Wenn wir geglaubt haben, das System müsste minimal viel starten. Weil du hast in dem System alles ausgedrückt. Wenn das passiert ist, startet das, das, das, das und das. Weil du nie weißt, wo du hinterher ankommen musst, musstest du einfach alles starten, was theoretisch gebraucht werden könnte am Schluss. Und das heißt, Upstart hat immer zu diesem Maximieren tendiert. Und wir sagten uns, du musst wissen, wo du hin willst. Und dann musst du daraus das Minimum berechnen, was du starten willst. Und niemals zum Maximum kommen. Wenn man das alles zusammennimmt, haben wir uns dann erst mal festgestellt, Upstart hat sich nicht mehr bewegt irgendwie. Die meisten Vorträge über Upstart waren nur das und das und das planig, anstatt das und das habe ich gemacht, von Scott damals. Und dann haben wir uns irgendwann hingesetzt und uns überlegt, irgendwie keine Sie was und ich. War auf dem Rückflug von einer Plumbers-Conference. Haben wir lange quasi zum Schluss gekommen, Upstart wird das nicht deliveren, weil es sich kaum mehr vorwärts bewegt und weil das, was wir glauben, dass es lösen müsste, eine komplette Auf-den-Kopf-Stellung ist. Weil es ist wirklich wörtlich eine Auf-den-Kopf-Stellung, weil wie gesagt, anstatt dass man irgendwie von oben runter geht, gehen wir von unten hoch. Von dem ist, was Upstart ist und das dachten wir, okay, das ist ein Grund, das kann man nicht fixen, das muss neu gemacht werden. Weil das ist irgendwie, du kannst fixen, wenn irgendwie was falsch ist. Dann kannst du es korrigieren oder so was Ähnliches, wenn es irgendwie klein ist. Aber wir dachten, okay, das ist zu fundamental. Das ist ein ganz anderes System, was hinterher rauskommt, wenn du deine Abhängigkeiten plötzlich alle immer so rumberechnen musst. Und das hat auch Ergebnisse gehabt, zum Beispiel bei, was Upstart nie konnte, ist, die Abhängigkeiten richtig hinkriegen für diesen Einfahrt, den ich schon erklärt habe, mit dem irgendwie die Festbade poppt ab, FS-Check läuft, Mount läuft und dann kannst du weiterbooten. Das haben die tatsächlich nie ausdrücken können. Stattdessen haben sie dann so ein Tool aufgerufen, das hieß Mountall, der hat den ganzen Mount-Kram gemacht und der hat dann am Schluss ein Event ausgelöst, weil er konnte diesen Abhängigkeitsbaum nicht richtig ausdrücken. Das war der Hintergrund. Wir haben uns halt überlegt irgendwie, das muss besser sein und das Alte geht nicht vorwärts. Und es war abzusehen, dass es nie in die Richtung gehen würde, dass es dieses harte Problem lösen würde. Also so hart ist das Problem auch nicht, aber diese ganzen Grafen-Theorie. Und dann haben wir das System geschrieben. Und am Anfang war es wirklich ganz genau das, was Upstart gemacht hat, also PIT1, ein Endesystem, so wie System 5.0 auch. Und hatte halt UNIX gehabt, dass du Abhängigkeiten ausdrücken konntest. Hat diese ganze Transaktionslogik gehabt, diese ganze Zyklen-Detection, was weiß ich noch alles. Und dann haben wir Stück für Stück mitgekriegt, dass der Boot-Prozess aber jetzt nicht nur PIT1 ist. Es ist nicht nur irgendwie irgendwas starten, sondern der Boot-Prozess ist halt viel mehr. Also, was weiß ich, da musst du irgendwelche SysControl Variablen schreiben. Musst du irgendwie dies und das Hardware proben und so weiter und so fort.
Logging.
Logging machen und so was. Und dann haben wir Stück für Stück uns überlegt, dass das auch noch von System.ly gemacht werden sollte. Also zum Beispiel Logging ist ein interessanter Fall. Weil wir haben uns immer überlegt, okay, was will eigentlich der Admin mit seinem Rechner machen? Oder was will er mit System.ly machen, also mit seinem Inet-System machen? Wenn System.ly-Services startet, will er wissen, von System.ly, wie geht es dem Service? Läuft er gerade? Wie lange läuft er? Und so weiter und so fort. Und das Wichtigste ist, wenn er nicht läuft, warum läuft er nicht? Und System 5.init war da extrem schlecht. Weil System 5.init, der wusste nicht mehr, wenn ein Damage stirbt, hat das niemand mitgekriegt. Weil der Colonel, das hat er einfach geriebt, er wusste nicht mehr, zu wem das gehört, dass da irgendwie ein Fehler passiert ist. Das war einfach wech. Dann konntest du raten. Dann hast du in Logs nachgeguckt, dann hast du Warlog-Messages durchgekreppt und geguckt, hat denn da der Damage, wo er gestorben ist, vielleicht mal was gelockt? Dann hast du das so textmäßig verglichen. Dann hast du rausgekriegt, das war das Problem. In Upstart ging das schon deutlich besser, weil Upstart wusste wenigstens den Hauptprozess von den Damages und konnte wenigstens sagen, es hat gesackvaulted oder wow, es ist gefailt mit Return-Codes und so. Aber wir haben uns überlegt, okay, das Allerwichtigste, was du über einen Service mitteilen willst, wenn er failt, ist nicht nur, dass er failt, sondern warum er gefailt ist. Das heißt, wir wollten diese einfache, also irgendwie nach außen hin, einfache scheinende Aufgabe lösen, zeig uns die Logs an von diesem Service. Sodass wenn du System Control Status, irgendwie Apache von Service machst, dass der anzeigt, okay, das hier ist der Grund, warum Apache gestorben ist. Aber das ist ein extrem schwieriges Problem. Zumindest mit klassischem Syslog. Weil klassisches Syslog ist nicht indiziert. Das sind einfach Textdaten, die da einfach so in einen Stream rausgeschrieben werden. Und die sind weder indiziert, noch sind die Daten, die da drin, sind reliable, also die sind weder immer da. Zum Beispiel hängt das irgendwie bei klassischem Syslog, ist es eine Entscheidung von dem Sender, ob er seine PID, also seine Prozess-ID, da inkludiert oder nicht. Und das haben die damals auch alle nicht gemacht. Da hat irgendwie ein komischer Dämmen gesagt, okay, ich bin FUBAR.
Irgend ein Programm, was irgendwie heißt, hat irgendwas getan irgendwann.
Und es war nicht trustable, weil es ein riesiges Problem ist in meinen Augen, oder war in meinen Augen.
Weil jeder auch reinschreiben kann.
Genau, da kann jeder, wenn jemand deine Maschine exploitet und es geschafft hat, irgendwie dein DRCP-Server zu exploiten, können die, die dir immer eine Meldung reinschreiben, sagen, ich bin der Patsche und ich bin irgendwie deine User-Datenbank und du hast gerade das Passwort so und so geändert, aber das hat nicht geklappt. Mach das mal bitte richtig oder so was, tipp mal diesen Befehl hier ein. Da kann man ja alles machen, wenn die Daten nicht verifiziert werden und jeder, jeder sein kann. Und da haben wir uns dann halt überlegt, okay, das kann nicht sein. Wir müssen, also irgendwie, wenn wir dem Admin irgendwie was Nettes zur Verfügung stellen wollen, dass er den Rechner gut administrieren kann, dann sollte System Control Status halt irgendwie alles anzeigen über den Status, den wir kennen, plus diese Logs. Und deswegen haben wir dann dieses Journal geschrieben. Journal ist indiziert und trusted. Also, der hat ein Konzept, dass was immer die Leute senden, wird erstmal weggeschmissen, wenn es nicht stimmt. Das heißt, wir kriegen nämlich vom Colonel die tatsächlichen Informationen. Das heißt, wenn jemand etwas schickt, dann wissen wir, welche Pit der hat, weil der Colonel es uns mitteilt. Und das kann der nicht faken. Das kann er höchstens faken, wenn er irgendwie hoch privilegiert ist. Weil, ja, Root kann alles, oder Superroot kann alles. Aber plötzlich hast du das Problem nicht mehr mit, wenn ein DRCP-Server als User DRCP läuft, dann hat er kein Recht, sich als Apache auszugeben. Und das Journal kriegt's mit. Und alles ist indiziert. Das heißt, wir können einfach irgendwie die Anfrage ans Journal schreiben, gib mir alles von Apache. Und wenn du dann System Control Status eintippst, zeigen wir das an. Aber ja, irgendwie oberflächlich betrachtet scheint das Problem ja ganz einfach zu sein, dass System Control Status alle Daten von Apache anzeigen soll. Aber tatsächlich das zu machen und das sicher zu machen, haben wir uns dann überlegt, okay, das müssen wir irgendwie was anderes machen. Irgendwie initial hatte ich sogar irgendwie mit dem Typen von Syslog geredet, dass er das für uns einbaut. Aber der hatte, sagen wir mal, andere Prioritäten. Der fand es nicht weiter interessant, irgendwelche solche Probleme. Das Journal macht auch noch andere Dinge, die wir irgendwie für Fehler hielten in dem klassischen Syslog. Syslog ist auch echt so eine UNIX-Sache von 1980, 1983 oder so kam das erste Syslog. Da gab es nie eine Spezifikation für das Protokoll. Da gab es nie eine Spezifikation für irgendwas. Sondern das haben einfach irgendwelche Leute da so hingehackt. Die Leute, die Sendmail gemacht haben, dachten, wir brauchen Systemlogger, damit wir irgendwelche Meldungen über Sendmail rausschreiben können. Haben sich dann da irgendwas kurz mal hingeschrieben.
Schick mir einen String und schreib das mal irgendwo hin.
Ganz genau. Und dafür ist es ganz cool.
Was schon in der Revolution war damals, übers Netz.
Aber die konnten sich nicht mehr darauf einigen, was in dem String drin sein soll. Ob die Pitt rein salte oder nicht.
Ich glaube, was halt damals ist immer so einfach, auf das Alter einzuschlagen. Mittlerweile auch gerechtfertigtermaßen, weil die Anforderungen sind natürlich jetzt andere. Wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie das überhaupt entstanden ist. Das sind ja dann überhaupt erst mal die Momente, wo man überhaupt diesen Bedarf entdeckt hat. Bevor man überhaupt sagen konnte, was wird das für Konsequenzen haben.
Warum das so passiert ist, wie es passiert ist. Und ich finde das total verständlich. Weil die Leute von Scentmail, die hatten kein Interesse, Logging-Probleme zu lösen. Die wollten Mailing-Probleme lösen. Wollten aber darüber loggen. Da haben sie gesagt, wir machen mal kurz diesen Log-Rahmen. Und das haben sie dann kurz gemacht. Und dann ist es halt so geworden, wie es geworden ist.
Tritt sich dann halt immer sehr schnell fest.
Ganz genau.
Aber eure Analyse war jetzt im Prinzip, ich meine, ausgehend von diesem einfachen, der Startprozess an sich ist schon mal blöd, unüberschaubar, komischer Code, setzt zu viel Herrschafts- und anderes Wissen hinaus hin zu der Feststellung, oha, das ist ja eigentlich so ein richtiges Westennest, was wir hier aufmachen. Weil wenn man erst mal anfängt, dieses Problem zu lösen, und wenn man es vor allem richtig lösen will, kommt man schnell auch in die, in diesen Problembereich rein, dass man eigentlich eine Integrität herstellen muss, um diese Integrität herstellen zu können, braucht man überhaupt erst mal ein Abbild dessen, was will man eigentlich laufen lassen, sodass das System zu jedem Zeitpunkt einen Blick hat. Das ist ja die Perspektive des Betriebssystems jenseits des Kernels, der eigentlich ja nur erst mal die Grundfähigkeiten der Hardware, der Software bereitstellt. Aber hier geht es ja wirklich um diesen Blick, was macht mein System aus? Was ist sozusagen, was bin ich eigentlich? Bin ich ein Server? Bin ich irgendetwas anderes? Welche Dienste muss ich bereitstellen? Und in welcher Abhängigkeit stehen die Dienste zueinander? Und was hat das dann eben für Implikation? Und natürlich Security, was so auch noch nie drin war, weil man eben heutzutage, wie wir gelernt haben, eben Software auch nicht unbedingt immer vertrauen kann. Das heißt, auch das System muss sich quasi gegenüber seinen eigenen Einwohnern schützen. Kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Ja, also für uns ist es auch immer besonders schwierig, rauszukriegen, was ist eigentlich System D? Also selber, also irgendwie, was gehört Service System D rein und was nicht? Und das ist eine schwierige Entscheidung, weil es gibt natürlich viele Leute, insbesondere im Internet, die meinen, System D macht viel zu viel. Und man kann das so sehen. Aber wir sehen es natürlich ein bisschen anders. Aber die Frage ist, irgendwie, wir überlegen uns auch immer selbst, wo ist denn eigentlich Schluss? Also, sicherlich, irgendwie, LibreOffice sollte nie in System D gematcht werden, das ist allen klar. Aber die Frage ist, wo ist die Grenze zu ziehen? Und für uns persönlich ist irgendwie, das, was in System D rein gehört, muss irgendwie allgemeingültig genug sein. Das heißt, irgendwie, was ganz, ganz wichtig ist für System D, ist, es muss alles generisch sein. Und es muss notwendig sein in, also häufig genug, notwendig sein für Systeme. Das heißt, es muss nicht nur irgendwie, nicht alles, was ein System in dir drin ist, wird auf jeder Maschine benötigt. Also, was weiß ich, da ist es zum Beispiel drin. Irgendwie RF Kill Support, der persistet, also der speichert auf der Festplatte einfach nur den Zustand von deinem WLAN-Switch am Laptop, ob jetzt gerade erlaubt ist oder nicht. Da kannst du sagen, okay, albern. Ja, die Antennen-Dings, dass du ausschalten kannst, das gerade rum, Offline-Modus, wie heißt denn das? Flugmodus kannst du sagen. Und das heißt RF-Kill auf einem Low-Level. Bei der Sache zum Beispiel kannst du natürlich total argumentieren, ich brauche ja keinen Mensch außer Laptops. Und das stimmt. Aber andererseits ist es trotzdem irgendwie noch total generisch, weil Embedded-Devices brauchen sie dann doch wieder, weil die haben das auch alle und die wollen das auch alle irgendwie haben. Und irgendwie, der Kram ist eigentlich so simpel, weil irgendwie kurz auf der Festphase zu sprechen, was der Zustand ist, finden wir dann irgendwie, dafür jetzt einen eigenen Package zu haben, ist ein bisschen crazy. Insofern, wir überlegen, es ist immer schwierig zu entscheiden, was gehört rein, was gehört nicht rein. Logging, für uns, gehört ganz klar rein. Auch wenn andere Leute damit irgendwie nicht übereinstimmen. Und es gibt auch Dinge, wo wir uns das immer noch mal anders überlegen. Also um einen.
Aber es ist eigentlich eine sehr interessante Aufgabe, weil in gewisser Hinsicht, durch System D und eure, genau durch diese Überlegung, was gehört rein, was gehört nicht rein, definiert ihr eigentlich auch das erste Mal, finde ich, einen weiteren Abstraktionslayer. Weil früher war das immer so, es gibt den Kernel und dann gibt es The Userland. Und das ist irgendwie jeder Prozess, der sich um alle möglichen Ressourcen boxen kann mit den anderen. Und um das Ganze überhaupt erstmal am Anfang ins Laufen zu bekommen, gibt's da halt so eine Rampe, so eine Rutsche, wo sie irgendwie alle sozusagen in dieses Userland hineinfallen und ab da ist es Herr der Ringe und Trolls und Krieger und alle boxen sich. Durch System D werden im Prinzip relevante Dinge definiert als Teil des Systems. So, nicht des Kernels, sondern des Systems. Und alles andere ist Anwendung. Kann man das so sagen, dass es sich eigentlich jetzt sehr viel klarer in drei Teile aufteilt, wo vorher eigentlich nur zwei waren?
Ja, es ist definitiv von dem Ziel irgendwie. Der Kernel ist einigermaßen standardisiert. Fast alle Leute, die irgendwie was machen mit heutzutage, nehmen den Liedungskernel und alle können sich darauf einigen. Was mit System D unser Ziel war, ist vielleicht so was Ähnliches zu erreichen für den Basic User Space. Weil irgendwie die Probleme, die da gelöst werden, alle lösen immer dieselben Probleme. Und irgendwie, bevor wir das mit System D vereinheitlicht haben, haben irgendwie Fedora und Debian und Visa alle, hier sind alle Distributionen verschiedene Start-up-Skripte benutzt. Die haben zwar irgendwie System 5.init benutzt, aber jenseits von dieser Codebase haben sie alles anders gemacht. Und es gibt auch keinen Grund dafür. Weil irgendwie, da gab es irgendwie, Susi hat den Host-Namen, diese total langweiligste aller Einstellungen, hat er gespeichert in etc.hostname mit großgeschriebenem Hostname. Debian hat es in etc.hostname mit kleingeschriebenem Hostname gemacht. Fedora und Redhead haben es gemacht in etc.sysconfig network. Alle anderen Distros haben es noch ganz anders gemacht. Und man fragte sich immer, was soll denn das?
Ihr könntet es nicht mal drauf einigen, wo ihr euren eigenen Namen speichert.
Das ist die langweiligste Einstellung. Das ist mein Lieblingsbeispiel. Es ist eine irrelevante Einstellung, eine notwendige Einstellung. Man kann sich darauf einigen, dass man das in eine Stelle macht. In Systemd.i haben wir einfach gesagt, wir supporten nichts anderes außer etc.hostname mit Debian-Fassung. Obwohl die Leute heute fast alle für Red Hat arbeiten, haben wir gesagt, Red Hat ist bescheuert an der Stelle, etc.sysconfig-network macht keinen Sinn. Wir nehmen das, was Debian macht, und nennen es etc.hostname, weil das am meisten Sinn macht. Unser Ziel war es definitiv, diese ganze Differenzierung von der Distribution auf dem Level, die bringt niemanden was. Die erzeugt Kosten höchstens. Kosten, die wir als Linux-Leute durchaus merken, weil es ist wahnsinnig schwierig, für Leute Software zu schreiben, für Linux. Weil wir haben so verschiedene Distributionen, die sich alle in Kleinigkeiten ändern, wie zum Beispiel, wie heißt der verdammte Hostname. Wenn wir jemals ein gesundes App-Environment haben wollen, wo irgendwie Leute Software für schreiben und auch bereit sind, einen Support dafür zu leisten, dann müssen wir ihnen das einfach machen. Das heißt, wir müssen ihnen eine Basis geben, wie sich das Betriebssystem immer gleich verhält, damit sie darauf aufsetzen können. Sicherlich ist das nicht die gesamte Lösung für dieses Problem, dass niemand Software für Linux schreibt, aber es ist zumindest Teil des Problems. Nicht, dass Linux jetzt keine Software hätte, von Leuten geschrieben, aber Linux hat vor allem Open-Source-Software, die Open-Source-developed wird, von Leuten, die sie selber anpassen können und in Distributionen maintained wird. Was meines Erachtens in Linux schon fehlt, ist irgendwie so eine App-Welt, wie sie Mac OS hat oder wie sie es sogar Windows heutzutage hingekriegt hat, wie Android das hat, weil die geben halt den Leuten, die dafür entwickeln, schon Garantien. Ja, das Betriebssystem verhält sich immer so. Du nimmst diese APs und dann kannst du sicher sein, dass es geht.
Und wenn es sich ändert, dann ändert es sich an einem definierten Ort mit einer definierten Dokumentation.
Und das heißt, die Entwickler, die brauchen das Ding einmal zu entwickeln und dann brauchen sie es zu supporten auf einem Betriebssystem. Während wenn irgendjemand so ein Software entwickeln würde für Linux, also das klassische Linux, dann kann er es schreiben für Dora, für Red Hat, für Suse, für Debian, für Ubuntu. Und das dann auch noch an alles verschiedenen Versionen. Weil irgendwie die Leute immer drei verschiedene Versionen gleichzeitig benutzen. Und was am aller schlimmsten ist, ist auch noch immer in verschiedenen Kombinationen. Weil unter Linux kannst du irgendwie das RPM so und so mit dem RPM so und so kombinieren oder das DEP so und so mit dem DEP in verschiedenen Versionen. Genau. Und das heißt, es ist einfach unmöglich für so Third-Party-Entwickler, das wirklich zu supporten, weil die müssen praktisch, also die Test-Matrix, diese Matrix gegen die sie ihren ganzen Kram testen wollen, die explodiert halt ins Irrsinnige, weil du hast Distros, du hast Versionen von Distros, du hast Pakete in verschiedenen Versionen. Und wenn du das alles mit allem kombinieren kannst, ist das ja wahnsinnig faszinierend. Und insofern, wir sind Betriebssystemleute, die Leute, die in unserem System gearbeitet haben. Und wir haben gesagt, okay, wir erkennen das Problem an, lassen uns irgendwie das Problem fixen, und irgendwie zumindest auf diesem Low-Low-Kram uns mal einfach darauf einigen, dass der Hostname jetzt mal ein ATC-Hostname ist. Das ist einfach, da kann niemand was gegen haben, das ist ein Bike-Shading-Problem, welches besser ist, aber es ist wirklich nicht mehr als ein Bike-Shading-Problem. Und wir legen jetzt fest, dass System D das ist. Natürlich können wir das nicht wirklich festlegen, weil wir können niemanden zu irgendwas zwingen, weil irgendwie alles, was wir machen, ist Software schreiben und die auf irgendeinen Server packen, und dann nehmen Leute das und bauen da irgendwas draus. Aber irgendwie den Mechanismus, den wir haben, ist, wir supporten eins immer in unserem Quelltext, und wenn Leute was anderes wollen, dann müssen sie die Änderung selber maintainen, und die werden wir nicht upstream merken. Und manche Leute finden das nicht nett von uns irgendwie, weil wir irgendwie sagen, gut, hast du es eben woanders gespeichert, dein Problem ist nicht unseres Problem. Aber ich glaube, der Outcome ist letztendlich ein guter, weil irgendwie das System da durch einheitlich wird.
Aber bietet denn das System-D-System selber auch eine API? Ich meine, wenn du jetzt sagst, der Hostnehmen ist ein EDC-Hostnehmen, dann heißt das ja nicht, dass alle Programme gesagt bekommen, ließ mal diese Datei aus, da steht es dann drin, sondern man will ja eigentlich auch weg von diesen ganzen alten Zöpfen.
Genau, also wir haben eine ganze Menge APIs. Wir haben D-Bus-APIs, also fast alle von unseren Demons, die wir haben, stellen D-Bus-APIs zur Verfügung.
Also D-Bus ist der Desktop-Bus?
Ja, das D stand mal für Desktop. Das tut schon lange nicht. Jetzt steht es nur für D. Also D-Bus ist irgendwie dieses IPC-System. Also Linux hatte nie ein wirklich gutes IPC, also Interprozesskommunikation. Genau. Hatte nie so ein richtig tolles System, mit dem Prozesse miteinander reden können. Alles, was sie hatten, war von UNIX her FIFOs, also das sind so Byte Streams, und Sockets. Genau. Und das heißt, so was wie ein Remote Method Call, also irgendwie jemanden, irgendwie eine Funktion in einem anderen Prozess und die Antwort wieder zurückzukriegen, hat Linux nie gekannt, wirklich nie standardisiert gekannt. Es gab da immer Ansätze und alle Leute haben sich selbst geschrieben. Was Linux wirklich gut konnte, ist Bytes austauschen. Was es überhaupt nicht konnte, Methoden-Aufrufe, also Funktions-Aufrufe, ob man es Funktion oder Methoden nennt oder Prozedur, ist einerlei.
Aber eine funktionale Verknüpfung von den einzelnen Komponenten in direkter Form.
Debus liefert das nach. Debus hat dann irgendwie das erste Mal das standardisiert unter UNIX, dass alle Leute sich darauf geeinigt haben, das zu benutzen zur Interprozesskommunikation. Und Systemd benutzt das halt auch. Und das Systemd ist fast alles, was Systemd kann, ist durch so ein Debus API zur Führung gestellt. Und das ist ganz moderner Kram mit, na gut, so modern ist das auch nicht mehr, das ist auch schon seit 15 Jahren, mit Objekt orientiert und was weiß ich noch, Interfaces. Alles, wie das heutzutage sein muss, ist type safe. Und man kann es introspekten und so was herauskriegen. Was gibt es eigentlich für APIs auf meinem System?
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt eine Komponente bereitstelle, kann ich beschreiben, welche Funktionalitäten sie hat, wie die Objekte heißen, wie man sie aufruft, welche Parameter dafür erforderlich sind. Eine andere Komponente kann sie sich das anschauen, analysieren, dann aufrufen, Daten hin und her übertragen, ohne dass man wissen muss, in welcher Programmiersprache das geschrieben ist.
Ganz genau, das ist eine wichtige Sache. Es gibt Bindings für Devos für jede Programmiersprache. Das heißt, wir haben unseren Kram in C geschrieben, aber wenn andere Leute andere Dienste anbieten können, können sie das in jeder Programmiersprache, die es auf der Welt gibt, ungefähr machen. Und die Clients können eine ganz andere Programmiersprache haben. Das Wichtige ist, wir haben uns gesagt, okay, Devos ist die Art und Weise, wie wir unsere Interfaces zur Verfügung stellen. Und das tun wir, und das tun wir konsequent für alles, was wir machen.
Und damit hat sozusagen das System überhaupt erst mal eine Sprache gefunden, mit der man sich untereinander unterhalten kann.
Genau, und das gelöst auch irgendwie lauter so Probleme, mit denen man sich vorher nicht so richtig auseinandersetzen wollte, wie interaktive Authentifizierung und sowas. Das heißt, wenn du einen Hostname setzt, dass irgendwie die Dialogbox aufpoppen kann auf deinem grafischen Benutzeroberfläche, die dich nach dem Passwort fragt, dass du es kannst. Oder nach dem Authentifizierung mit dem Finger. Oder was auch immer du konfiguriert hast. Aber die löst halt diese ganze Problemsatz, irgendwie Debo, PolicyKit und dieser ganzen Kram, dass irgendwie das so funktioniert, wie ein heutiges System funktioniert und nicht alles irgendwie mit Sudo oder SU und Passwort basiert auf der Kommando-Seite stattfindet. Insofern, wir haben solche Apis. Wir haben aber auch allerlei C-Apis. Zum Beispiel das Journal, also diese Logging-Framework, was wir da haben, hat einen C-Api, weil da will man nicht immer über ePc gehen, aus Geschwindigkeitsgründen. Weil wenn du so richtig viele Logs hast, dann wirst du damit direkt auf die Festplatte gehen.
Also man braucht auch so ein Low-Level-Zugang.
Genau. Und wir haben ein paar andere Apis. Selbst für D-Bus haben wir ein eigenes Api gemacht. Wir haben eine ganze Menge Apis. Wir raten den Leuten, die Apis auch zu benutzen. Aber das heißt natürlich immer, wenn die Leute sie benutzen, dann läuft sie unter Systemd. Was ich einen total okayen Deal finde. Manche Leute finden das nicht so toll.
Aber die Systeme, die Systemd ersetzt, hatten ja so etwas gar nicht.
Genau, die hatten fast nie solche Apis, das stimmt. Für ein Logging-Api, das zum Suchen benutzen konnte, gab es nicht. Einen Hostname zu setzen, haben alle Leute selber gemacht, indem sie kurz im Dateilystem rumgefummelt haben. Dann hatten sie 1.000 if-devs, um rauszukriegen, ich bin gerade unter Debian oder nach Fedora, und das ist die Datei, die ich zugreifen muss.
Habt ihr euch denn bei diesen ganzen Design-Fragen, wie denn das sozusagen alles zu gestalten und zu machen ist? Wenn man jetzt erstmal am Anfang steht, dann gibt es ja alle Möglichkeiten, und nicht alles, was einem am Anfang sinnvoll erscheint, beweist sich am Ende, wie man ja immer wieder merkt. Habt ihr euch andere Systeme angeschaut, wie andere UNIX-er das Problem lösen?
Ja, das war immer sehr wichtig für uns. Weil dieser Blick über den Tellerrand, halte ich immer noch für absolut essentiell. Man sollte nicht irgendwie versuchen, sowas allgemeingültig zu lösen, wenn man nicht weiß, was die Allgemeinheit nun mal macht. Deswegen, als wir System-Di angefangen haben, habe ich lange Zeit damit verbracht, erst mal zu lesen, was hat Apple gemacht mit LaunchD und was hat Solaris gemacht mit SMF und sogar was hat Windows gemacht mit seinem Service Manager. Weil irgendwie, sicherlich, wenn man es nicht so implementieren vielleicht, wie die es gemacht haben, aber man kann halt doch sehr viel davon lernen.
Hast du mal ein Beispiel dafür, was sozusagen ermunternde Information war, wo ihr vielleicht Konzepte auch so übernommen habt oder explizit auch rausgelassen habt?
Also zum Beispiel bei Apple, in LaunchD gibt es das Konzept von Soccer Activation. Ich finde das total toll. Leider wird es unter Linux nicht so häufig benutzt, wie ich das gerne hätte. Aber Soccer Activation ist so ein Konzept, wo du, also Apple's LaunchD benutzt das für ungefähr das ganze Service Management. Und das sieht dann halt so aus, dass Services nicht hochfahren, dann irgendwie die Sockets und IPC, was sie sonst noch so haben, establishen und dann warten, bis jemand darauf reagiert.
Also ein Webserver zum Beispiel?
Nein, ein Webserver ist ein schlechtes Beispiel. Es ist mehr auf Lokales fokussiert. Also was weiß ich. Apple zum Beispiel hat einen Sound-Server oder so was Ähnliches, Core Audio oder wie es heißt. Oder irgendwie ein Service, der dies oder jenes macht, Bluetooth macht oder was weiß ich noch alles. Und diese ganzen Services haben ja ein IPC-Interface, dass Programme mit denen reden können. Und klassischerweise, unter UNIX geht das so, der Service startet, registriert sich dann mit einem IPC-System, registriert ein Socket, was auch immer, und sagt, hier bin ich. Wenn jemand mit mir reden will, sprich mit mir. Bei Apple ist das alles rausgezogen worden. Das heißt, die haben gesagt, okay, wenn jemand mit diesem reden will, dieser DEMON macht das, aber ich starte den DEMON erst, wenn jemand danach fragt. Das ist die eine Sache, die sie gemacht haben. Die andere Sache, die sie gemacht haben, okay, Leute, die damit reden wollen, können sofort damit reden. Ich werde das gleich auch starten, aber momentan ist es noch nicht gestartet. Aber wenn jemand eine Anfrage dahinstellt, und es noch nicht gestartet ist, werde ich es queueen, bis es gestartet ist, und das dann ausliefern. Diese Art von Socket-Activation oder jeder Art von Activation, wo die Garantie ist, alle Services sind immer ansprechbar, egal, ob sie laufen oder nicht. Wenn sie nicht ansprechbar sind, wird der Request reingecue und wird dann tatsächlich ausgeführt, wenn der Service hochgefahren ist. Dies ist großartig für Stabilität, das ist großartig für Parallelisierung, und das macht das ganze System einfacher, weil die ganzen Abhängigkeiten dadurch eigentlich verloren gehen.
Und man muss nicht die ganzen Prozesse schon laufen haben, was auch weniger Ressourcen baut.
Ganz genau, man kann diesen lazy Kram machen. Man tut so, als ob alles läuft, tut es aber gar nicht.
Weil man aktiviert das erst in dem Moment, wo es gebraucht wird. Und bei dieser Socket-Activation ist es sozusagen wirklich auch der tatsächliche Zeitpunkt des Eintreffens einer Anfrage, wo es überhaupt erst startet. Also sozusagen maximal lazy.
Ganz genau. Ja, aber die meisten Services bei Mac OS sind nicht solche lazy Services allerdings. Der Druck-Server ist so ein lazy Service, aber viele von den anderen, die werden immer gestartet. Das weiß ich, dein Audioserver, weil der schon ping macht beim booten, brauchst du natürlich immer. Insofern ist das lazy eine Facette, aber das ist nicht die einzige Facette. Weil selbst wenn du die socket-Aktivierung benutzt, da, also stell dir mal vor, du hast Syslog und dein Sound-Server. Und der Sound-Server möchte gerne loggen zu Syslog. Mit der socket-Aktivierung brauchst du jetzt nicht irgendwie so auszudrücken, starte erst Syslog, warte bis es fertig ist, starte dann den Sound-Server, sondern du kannst beide gleichzeitig starten. Solange du diesen Syslog-Kommunikationskanal schon vorher eingerichtet hast, was eben LaunchD macht. Weil das Ergebnis wäre dann, Chores, dieser Kommunikationskanal wird eingerichtet, der Syslog-Kommunikationskanal wird eingerichtet, dann starten wir beide in Parallel, komplett Parallel. Sobald Chore-Audio irgendwas loggt, schreibt er das in diesen Syslog-Socket rein. Wenn Syslog läuft gut, wird sofort irgendwie auf die Festweite geschrieben. Wenn nicht, wird es da drin geqt. Und irgendwann, wenn Syslog dann hoch ist, wird es rausgeschrieben. Das heißt, du hast diese ganze Abhängigkeit im Feldwerk und alles ist plötzlich total parallel. Weil wir starten einfach Syslog und Chore-Audio parallel und das Betriebssystem kümmert sich darum irgendwie parallel und asynchroten. Ganz genau. Und das geht sogar ein bisschen. Das ist eine total tolle Technik, weil irgendwie du kannst auch Syslog dann einfach killen. Überhaupt gar kein Problem, weil der Socket bleibt die ganze Zeit erreichbar, weil das ist ja gar nicht Syslog, der den erreichbar gemacht hat. Das ist ja schon dieses Launch, das es im vorigen Schritt gemacht hat. Das heißt, wenn die nächste Request reinkommt auf dem Socket, startet er einfach Syslog neu und der Client kriegt es nicht mit und keine Nachricht geht verloren. Insofern, das ist ein total tolles Konzept. Als wir das irgendwie verstanden haben von LaunchD, haben wir gesagt, okay, das wollen wir auch für SystemD. SystemD macht das auch. Leider benutzen die Leute das nicht so umfangreich unter SystemD, wie sie es unter LaunchD benutzen, weil LaunchD hat gesagt, wir machen nichts anderes als das. Wenn du irgendwie gestartet werden willst und Anfragen anstellen willst, dann musst du das so machen. Ein Abhängigkeitssystem, das supporten die gar nicht. Was limitierend ist für die, weil deswegen können sie den ganzen... Unter MacOS ist der erste Teil des Boots, nicht von LaunchD wird er nicht gemacht, sondern das ist einfach auch ein Shell-Script und sowas. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es immer noch ein Shell-Script ist. War es aber lange. Und der hat dann einfach als letzten Step startet der LaunchD, der dann alle Demons gleichzeitig parallel startet.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile werden auch so die ganzen Treiber und so weiter, da sind die Shell-Scripten jetzt auch rausgeflogen in den letzten Versionen.
Sehr gut. Aber ja, wir wollten irgendwie das alles, wir haben das versucht zu verheiraten. Die dependency-Kram, weil wir es brauchen für den early-boot-Teil. Und Service-Aktivierung für den Rest. Weil die meisten UNIX-Demons aber nicht so geschrieben sind, dass sie Service, also socket-Aktivierung und sowas machen, sind es vor allem unsere eigenen Dinger, die socket-aktiviert sind. Und irgendwie DoveCod und ein paar Leute, die irgendwie die Zukunft gesehen haben, haben das auch so gemacht. Insbesondere die, die nach MacOS portabel sind, weil man bei MacOS auch so was braucht. Aber leider ist es nicht so häufig benutzt, wie ich es gerne hätte. Ich hätte gerne das ganze Betriebssystem so aufgebaut, aber die einzige Art und Weise, wie man da wohl hinkäme, ist, wenn man sagen würde, das andere gibt es nicht mehr, so wie MacOS das gemacht hat. Aber wir sind halt nicht MacOS, wir können nicht so hart sein. Aber das ist zum Beispiel so...
Kann man sich aber sozusagen mit der Zeit alles noch entwickeln?
Ja, aber das ist zum Beispiel so eine Sache, wo das ist Inspiration, die wir von Apple übernommen haben, und wo Apple total tolles Design gemacht hat. Und wir haben gesagt, okay, das wollen wir auch. Und wir wollen es noch besser. Und unsere Implementation ist glaube ich auch ein bisschen mächtiger, weil wir können alle Arten von Aktivierung haben und was weiß ich noch alles. Aber ja, und wir haben auch... Bei Solaris? Bei Solaris haben wir eine ganze Menge auch übernommen. Was Solaris ganz gut hatte, waren diese Project IDs, Contract IDs heißt das. Wir hatten immer das Problem, in Daemon ist eine oder mehrere Prozesse zur Laufzeit. Das heißt, Apache ist der Apache Hauptprozess. Das ist der Apache Prozess, also gibt es das Worker Prozesse, irgendwie kannst du konfigurieren.
Die Connections annehmen und so weiter.
Und die forken dann wieder irgendwelche CGI-Scripts weg, was nochmal Prozesse sind. Das heißt, wenn du den Service als Ganzen betrachtest, ist es eine Sammlung von Prozessen. Einer davon ist der Hauptprozess. Was uns immer ganz wichtig war, ist, wir haben uns überlegt damals schon, eine von den wichtigsten Aufgaben, die wir machen müssen mit SystemD, ist, dass man einen Service sauber beenden kann. Und das hört sich an wie eine ganz einfache Sache. Und System5.init hat das ja auch schon immer gekonnt, denkt man. Aber tatsächlich ist es eine extrem schwierig umzusetzende Sache. Weil, wenn du so einen Dienst hast wie Apache, der einmal forkt und noch 16 mal forkt, und dann noch die ganze CGI-Skripte und die CGI-Skripte können Shell-Skripte ausführen und was weiß ich noch allem, dann geht es im klassischen System5 nicht, dass man wirklich vollständig in einen Service runterfährt. Weil man weiß gar nicht, was gehört zu dem Service dazu.
Weil man die Geschichte nicht hat, welcher Prozess hat wann, welchen Prozess gestartet.
Ganz genau. Irgendwie fehlt dieser Zusammenhang. Man kann nicht einfach das System fragen, hey, was sind alle Prozesse, die Apache gestartet hat? Das System weiß es selbst nicht. Du kannst unter UNIX doppelforken, also ein klassischer Doppelfork, und dann hast du keine Beziehung mehr zu deinem ursprünglichen Vater. Das ist explizit wech. Das ist aber ein Problem für einen Service-Manager. Weil ein Service-Manager will das wissen. Wenn wir irgendwie was killen, dann willst du wissen, dass du Apache tötest und nicht nur Apache tötest, sondern auch noch alles, was die Kinder weggeforkt haben. Das ist auch immer wieder übrigens ein Sicherheitsproblem. Weil das Sicherheitsproblem ist, wenn jemand es geschafft hat, deinen CGI-Script zu exploiten und macht dann eine Shell auf und macht dann da einen Double Fork, dann ist er deiner Processor-Supervision entkommen auf System 5.0.
Dann denkt man, man hat irgendwie den Apache runtergefahren, kann ja nichts mehr passieren und dabei fängt er die ganze Zeit noch in der Ecke.
Genau, was der Einbrecher gemacht haben kann, der hat sich eine Shell gestartet, hat dir aber einen anderen Namen gegeben, irgendwas Unverfängliches, hat gedoppeforkt, sitzt dann da als Prozess, irgendwie heißt es zum Beispiel Syslog oder so was, du tippst PS ein und hast keine Ahnung, was das ist. Insofern für uns war das wichtig, irgendwie killen muss möglich sein. Solaris hatte jetzt dafür ein Konzept, das heißt Contract Addies. Contract Addies ist bei denen so ein Kernkonzept, das kannst du einmal setzen für den Hauptprozess von einem Service und diese Contract Addies werden dann alle runter vererbt an alle Kindprozesse. Du kannst das System fragen, was gehört alles zu Contract Addies und dann siehst du halt, das sind die Prozesse. Wir haben so was Ähnliches gesucht unter Linus, weil wir sagten, das wollen wir.
Also so ein Vererbungsmerkmal, was einen Prozess auch nicht abschütteln kann. Wenn das einmal gesetzt ist, dann ist er immer dabei und da kann man noch so viel forken. Man ist da immer so ein Zeichen.
Weil es UNIX ist, man kann immer alles abschütteln, wenn man die nötigen Privilegien hat. Aber es kommt immer auf die Privilegien an. Doppelforken unter UNIX kann jeder. Das Abschütteln ist komplett unprivilegiert. Ein CGI-Script, das mit wenigstmöglichen Privilegien läuft, kann sich einfach abschütteln, kein Problem.
Aber ja, Contract-Leer, gab es auch da mal so Process Groups oder sowas?
Process Groups sind ganz speziell für Unused Cases und für Shells, also für Shell Pipelines sind die notwendig. Wir haben versucht, das irgendwie dafür zu benutzen, aber das geht letztendlich nicht.
Aber dann gibt es sozusagen den Mechanismus gar nicht, den ihr brauchtet?
Doch, und zwar haben wir den gefunden in einem Konzert, was C Groups heißt, Control Groups, vielleicht mal von gehört. Das haben die damals erfunden unter Linux, um Ressources zu managen, also um Ressourcen und irgendwie so Prozessortseite zu managen. Das heißt, du hattest irgendwie Apache laufen, du hattest MySQL laufen. Apache hat 16 Worker Shreds gehabt, MySQL hat zwei Worker Shreds gehabt. Nach klassischen UNIX hieß es, Apache würde achtmal so viel CPU kriegen wie MySQL. Weil es hat halt achtmal so viele Prozesse. Und die haben sich damals überlegt, das kann ja nicht sein, auf heutigen Systemen muss man das anders managen können, und haben dieses Control Groups Konzept erfunden. Control Groups sind so eine Hierarchie, wo du Prozesse in Gruppen passen kannst. Wenn ein Prozess forkt, ist der Kindeprozess automatisch Mitglied in derselben Gruppe. Und du kannst diesen Gruppen Namen geben. Der Hintergrund, wie gesagt, original, ist immer Resource Management. Dass du sagen kannst, fass das jetzt hier als Einheit an. Gib vielleicht noch ein Limit an, dass du sagst, mehr als so und so viel CPU-Zeit kriegst du auf keinen Fall. Selbst wenn er verfügbar wäre und solche Dinge. Und wir haben uns überlegt, Resource Management, sehr nutzliche Sache sowieso. Aber wir können dieses Grouping, was es da gibt, auch wirklich für unsere Management-Probleme lösen. Ohne dass wir tatsächlich das Resource-Management-Teil von den C-Groups benutzen, können wir einfach damit Dinge gruppieren. Und wenn wir Dinge kopieren können, können wir damit dieses Kill-Problem lösen. Weil wir können dann einfach, wir packen den Service Apache in eine C-Group mit dem Namen Apache. Und wenn wir dann den Colonel fragen, ja, was gibt es für Prozesse in den C-Group Apache, dann lässt er uns genau alles auf, was in Apache drin ist. Und wir können auch andersherum fragen, zu welcher C-Group gehört dieser Prozess. Und er sagt uns, aha, es ist Apache.
Und es ist nicht nur so eine Masse von Prozess-IDs, sondern es ist auch die komplette Forking, auch mit drin abgebildet.
Ganz genau. Man kann alles irgendwie daraus rauskriegen, was genau dazu gehört. Wir benutzen das, und das haben wir uns halt bei SMF sozusagen abgeguckt. Ein ganz anderes Konzept letztendlich, wo wir angekommen sind unter Linux, weil unter SMF sind diese Contracte, die sind Nummern und die sind nicht hierarchisch. Unter Linux mit den C-Groups ist es irgendwie mächtiger, weil die sind hierarchisch und du hast Namen. Das heißt, du kannst tatsächlich dir so ein Tree rausholen, wie dein System aufgebaut ist. Das ist auch ganz toll unter Linux heutzutage, weil du kannst, weil das hierarchisch ist, haben wir das so gemacht, dass Container und das Betriebssystem selbst so einen Baum bauen sind, wo dann, wenn du System D auf dem Host laufen lässt, hast du so ein paar Gruppen, und wenn du dann System D in einem Container auf demselben Host laufen lässt, dann ist das halt ein Subbaum, noch mal das Gleiche unten drunter. Insofern haben wir uns von SMF abgeguckt, aber dann komplett neu erfunden, aber irgendwie die Logik dahinter war total toll. Und ja, sowas brauchten wir. Aber genau, wir haben uns irgendwie viel Zeit gegeben, irgendwie rauszukriegen, was machen andere Leute, was ist geil, was können wir unter Linux nachbauen, und wie machen wir das am besten, und können wir das mit irgendwas anderem verheiraten. Also, ich glaube, so sollte jeder irgendwie ein Wissenschaftler arbeiten und ein Ingenieur, ein Software-Ingenieur insbesondere, sollte das auch tun.
Ja, das ist ja immer dieses Not-Invented-Hier-Syndrom, was einen dann häufig erschlägt, dass man halt immer denkt, so, ha, ja, ja.
Ja, wird uns ja häufig auch vorgeworfen, aber ich sehe es alles meistens ein bisschen anders. Also, irgendwie zum Beispiel...
Euch wird vorgeworfen, dass ihr darunter leidet.
Ja, häufig irgendwie, weil wir halt irgendwie, wir sagen, okay, wir machen unser eigenes Logging-System, wir machen nicht Syslog. Oder wir machen Systemd und nicht Upstart. Aber in jedem einzelnen Fall haben wir uns lange drüber nachge- überlegt, warum wir das tun sollten. Also ein System, der, wie gesagt, war es dieser Fall, wo wir überlegt haben, es ist substanziell falsch rum, irgendwie, wie Upstart designt worden ist, müssen wir was eigenes machen. Und bei Syslog war es das Gleiche, weil wir uns überlegt haben, irgendwie, dieser ganze Kram, dass es nicht indiziert ist und nicht getrusted ist und dieser ganze Kram. Irgendwann kommen beide Punkte an. Ja, wir müssen das machen, weil irgendwie, aus diesen Gründen, und das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass es nicht uns gehört oder sowas Ähnliches. Sondern es hat einfach damit zu tun, dass wir irgendwie in einer alten Lösung zu viele Probleme sahen. Und auch irgendwie heutzutage merkt man sogar noch viel mehr, oder merke ich zumindest noch viel mehr, warum das die richtige Entscheidung war. Weil wir haben jetzt immer solche Probleme, wie wir haben Dibus Dämmen, der diesen IPC-Teil macht. Wir haben Systemd selbst, der das System hochgefahren hat. Und wir haben Logging. Diese drei Teile sind unheimlich basal jeweils. Die sind irgendwie, würde man zu den drei low-levelsten Teilen des Systems zählen. Jetzt haben wir aber immer das Problem, dieses Journal, die Logging-Komponente, möchte gerne IPC benutzen, also Dibus. Dibus möchte gerne mit PID 1 reden, also dem Inet-System. Das Inet-System möchte loggen und IPC benutzen. Das heißt, da hat man diese drei Komponenten. Und die haben immer Dependencies zwischen einander. Das heißt, der eine möchte jeweils die anderen benutzen. Dibus möchte gerne über PID 1 Dinge aktivieren, aber PID 1 möchte auch Dienste auf Dibus anbieten. Diese Cyclic-Dependencies, diese zyklischen Abhängigkeiten, die sind ein Riesenproblem. Und die kriegen wir nur deswegen in Kontrolle, weil wir das eng miteinander verzahnt haben und das innerhalb von Systemdaten tun können, zumindest für das Logging und für das PID 1. Aber es war überhaupt nicht möglich, diese Probleme zu lösen und diese Logging-Komplexität unter einen Hut zu kriegen, dass PID 1 auch dahin loggt. Und der klassische Syslogger, der klassische Syslogger, das war ein DEMON wie jeder andere auch. Der ist im Late Boot gestartet. Und bis der gestartet ist, gab es kein Logging.
Im Prinzip ist das das Ergebnis der ganzen Überlegungen, dass man sagt, was braucht ein System? Es braucht das Launching, es braucht das Logging und es braucht die Kommunikation.
Ja, das sind die drei absolute Basale.
Und das sind sozusagen die drei Kerndienste, die quasi nach dem Kernel kommen. Das ist sozusagen das erste, was man neu schaffen muss.
Ganz ehrlich, der IPC-Kram gehört meines Erachtens in den Kernel rein. Weil es ist irgendwie total albern, dass das im User-Space ist. Und deswegen haben wir auch dieses KDEVOS-Kram gemacht, aber was leider nicht gerade schnell ging. Aber die Idee ist dann irgendwie, dass wir behaupten, manche von den Teilen, die sind so low-level, die sollten nicht im User-Space sein, die müssen in den Kernel reingemacht werden. Und DEVOS ist eins davon. Also System.ly selbst soll nicht in den Kernel rein. Das ist ja stetig definiert als der erste Teil, der nach dem Kernel kommt. Logging willst du auch im User-Space haben, weil du in Netzwerken, wo du alles machen musst, strukturieren. Aber der IPC-Teil sollte in den Kernel sein.
So wie es bei Mac OS zum Beispiel ist.
Nicht nur bei Mac OS, bei allen Betriebssystemen bis auf Linux. Aber ja, ich hoffe, das erklärt unsere Denkweise, warum wir das machen. Und dass wir wirklich harte technische Gründe haben, warum wir Journal machen. Und dass es eben nicht NIH ist. Ich fasse das Entschuldigung? Nicht, dass es not invented here ist. Wir haben richtig komplizierte Probleme, die wir da lösen müssen und die wir nicht anders lösen können. Das Journal ist übrigens auch eine ganz andere Sache, warum wir das unbedingt haben wollten. Weil, wofür braucht man Logging, um Probleme zu lösen? Wofür sind die größten Probleme im System, die man lösen will? Das war ein Boot-Prozess, ja wohl. Wenn man ins Internet geht, werden die Leute am meisten sich darüber beschweren, dass sie ihr Linux nicht hochfahren können. Was gab es unter System 5.init für Logging an der Stelle? Da gab es gar nichts, weil, wie gesagt, ich habe es eben schon erwähnt, der klassische Syslog-Damon ist im Late-Boot gestartet worden, als ganz normaler Damon, zum gleichen Zeitpunkt praktisch wie der Apache.
Also man konnte gar nicht loggen?
Genau, der ganze vordere Teil des Boots war eine Lockwüste. Da gab es nicht wirklich was. Der Colonel hat in sich selbst das K-Message gelockt. Dann war Ruhe. Der early-userspace hat erstmal gar nichts gelockt. Dann haben die devian-Leute und die meisten anderen Distros so etwas erfunden, weil es Bootloggede hieß. Bootloggede, was es gemacht hat, es hat vom Bildschirm heruntergelesen, was draufgeschrieben worden ist für Fehlermeldungen. Also anstatt dass irgendwie die Fehlermeldungen gelockt worden sind und dann auch noch auf den Bildschirm landen, damit der Admin was davon hat, ist es auf den Bildschirm gebracht worden, auf die TTYs, und dann wieder runtergezogen worden, um es auch noch in eine Log-Datei zu schreiben. Mit Anziehsequenzen, damit es bunt war und was weiß ich noch mehr. Wir haben gesagt, das kann nicht sein. Irgendwie was wichtig ist für uns, Logging muss da sein, muss immer da sein, muss sowas Basales sein. Und alles, was im System passiert, wenn es ganz früher Boot ist, wenn es im Kern ist, wenn es in der Idee ist, wenn es Early Boot ist, wenn es Late Boot ist, beim Runterfahren, alles muss gelockt werden, weil das ist unsere Aufgabe. Das ist unsere verdammte Aufgabe. Irgendwie, wenn wir ein System bauen, dass der Admin die Möglichkeit hat, an diese Daten ranzukommen. Insofern, keine Ahnung. Die Leute werden uns immer weiter vorwerfen, NIH, ich glaube, wir haben bei allem, was wir da so angefangen haben, unsere Hausaufgaben gemacht. Und uns wirklich Mühe gegeben, rauszukriegen, warum wir diese anderen Komponenten nicht einlösen. Und warum wir unsere eigenen Kram machen. Und warum wir nicht das andere fixen, anstatt es neu zu machen.
Ja, und im Falle von Debus, das war ja auch schon vorher da.
Genau, Debus wird weiterhin benutzt. Aber na gut, wir machen auch uns das Neue mit Cardibus. Wir wollen schon den Debus-Damant irgendwie loswerden, auf lange Sicht. Und stattdessen IPC haben, was direkt im Kern funktioniert. Aber irgendwie, das ist auch so ein Fall, ich war für eine Zeit der Debus-Mentainer. Das ist auch nur irgendwie, ist nicht, dass wir da irgendwie was von anderen Leuten wegnehmen oder sowas. Wir nehmen uns fast selber weg. Also, das ist nicht irgendwie, das hat uns sowieso schon gehört.
Ich denke, das macht auch eine gute Softwareentwicklung oder überhaupt auch eine gute Systementwicklung an sich aus. Dass man einfach auch bereit ist, irgendwann mal alte Zöpfe abzuschneiden.
Ja, das sind wir sicherlich breiter als viele andere. Ich kann auch verstehen, wenn Leute das nicht gut finden, weil wir benutzen unsere Software auf meinem Laptop. Ich habe einen Server im Internet, aber das war's. Ich bin nicht jemand, der tatsächlich Admin ist und 500 Web-Server betreiben muss.
Oder 30.000 Embedded-Devices.
Ganz genau. Und es ist mir klar, dass das so ist. Natürlich ist es für mich viel einfacher, Dinge abzuschneiden, als es Leuten wäre, die tatsächlich mitarbeiten müssen. Aber ich kann wenigstens sagen, ich gebe mir die Mühe, um es zu verstehen und was damit zu tun. Ich bin ja Entwickler letztendlich. Natürlich muss ich nach vorne denken, nicht zurückdenken. Das ist ja irgendwie dieser Widerspruch. Wir kriegen das immer mit. Ich arbeite ja für Red Hat. Die Kunden von Red Hat kommen immer an. Wir möchten gerne alles, immer das Neueste, aber bitte schon fünf Jahre getestet. Das kann es ja nicht lösen, das Problem. Das wird nicht gehen. Ich tendiere natürlich eher immer an die vordere Ende der Entwicklung zu gehen, da, wo es Bleeding Edge ist. Und Admins tendieren natürlich eher dahin, dass es gerade alles funktioniert, nicht berühren oder so etwas Ähnliches, nicht etwas Neues machen. Es ist schwierig, das Problem zu lösen. Man kann es, glaube ich, nicht lösen. Aber ich bringe Verständnis auf. Die Leute glauben nicht, dass wir das immer tun. Aber ich glaube, wir sind uns schon sehr viel bewusster, weil wir das immer tun. Das ist das, was wir da eigentlich genau machen, als die Leute glauben, dass wir das tun.
Wenn du wir sagst, welches Team arbeitet derzeit an System D, wie groß muss man sich das so vorstellen, die Truppe?
Es kommt darauf an, wie man die Truppe definiert. Wenn man sich anguckt, wer alles Beiträge zum Projekt liefert, auf GitHub, dann sind das sehr viele Leute. Ich sollte vielleicht mal die neuen Statistiken berechnen, da seitdem ihr zu GitHub gewechselt habt, ist da vermutlich noch viel mehr, als es vorher war. Aber wir haben da Leute von 15 Firmen, die hatten damals 15 verschiedene Hintergründe, nicht alles Firmen, hatten damals Commit Access, bevor wir zu GitHub gewechselt sind. Wir haben immer Patches von mehr als 70 Leuten pro Monat gekriegt, verschiedenen Leuten pro Monat gekriegt. Die engste Truppe von den tatsächlichen Maintainern sind fünf oder so etwas, die die Vollzeit dran arbeiten. Bei Red Hat haben wir eine System-League-Gruppe, darin sind acht Leute. Davon Maintain drei oder so etwas, das ist ein Rail. Wir machen einen kommerziellen Support dafür und stellen sicher, dass es ein Rail is up-to-date ist. Und die anderen sorgen dafür, dass in Rail 7 die Bugs gefixt werden und die Leute, wenn sie ein Problem haben, auf ein Bug-Report eine Antwort kriegen. Die fünf anderen, davon bin ich einer, beschäftigen uns vor allem damit, irgendwie Neues zu entwickeln. Und wie es so will, sind fast alle von den fünf, also vier von den fünf, sind in Berlin. Und wir treffen uns ja auch häufiger mal, also fast jede Woche oder häufiger als jede Woche, und essen und sprechen und hacken und was weiß ich noch alles. Also ein einziger von uns kommt aus Norwegen, aber alle anderen sind hier in Berlin. Und das ist eigentlich ganz genial, weil man irgendwie doch, auch wenn irgendwie alles übers Internet stattfindet heutzutage, ist es doch schon ganz schön vorteilhaft, auch mal den Leuten ins Gesicht zu gucken und einfach loszuquasseln.
Um jetzt mal diese Komplexität von System, die wir vielleicht auch noch mal von der anderen Seite nachzuvollziehen, und ich habe ja auch bewusst hier den Titel gesetzt, so Linux System, System D ist ein bisschen der Katalysator, der jetzt sozusagen als neue Software-Komponente hineingekommen ist, wie ich das vorhin schon ausgeführt habe, sodass man überhaupt erstmal Körner, System und der Rest von einander trennen kann. Trotzdem hängt das natürlich alles sehr eng miteinander zusammen. Können wir vielleicht mal den Rechner einschalten und mal gucken, wo wir da eigentlich hinkommen? Also wenn man jetzt heute so eine normale PC-Architektur nimmt und vielleicht nehmen wir einfach mal so eine normale Moderne, wie es sich jetzt sozusagen abzeichnet. Was passiert da, was aktiviert sich und wann kommt ein Kernel und wann kommt system.de ins Spiel?
Also irgendwie ein moderner Laptop, der hat ja so ein EFI-Bios. Und ein EFI-Bios ist halt irgendwie so ein Standard, den gibt es jetzt auch schon gleich 15 Jahre, aber in den letzten 7 Jahren sind alle Laptops und alle Desktop und alle Server fangen an, das tatsächlich zu benutzen. Aber das ist so ein Betriebssystem, was sich ein bisschen anfühlt wie DOS, aber 32-bitig ist und deswegen auch sich ein bisschen anfühlt wie Windows, ist in das Bios reingebrannt, also in den Chip, also es ersetzt das alte Bios sozusagen. Und was das Unternehmen drin hat, ist ein Festbattentreiber und ein FAT-Dateisystem. Und mit diesem FAT-Dateisystem-Treiber sucht es dann eine ganz bestimmte markierte Partition auf der Festbatte. Und da drin sucht es ein Programm unter einem ganz bestimmten Namen und den führt es aus. Und dieses Programm ist ein sogenanntes EFI-Programm und das ist einfach so wie so eine Exo-Datei auf der Windows ist. Es ist sogar tatsächlich eine Exo-Datei, weil es ist PE, also Portable Executable as in the Windows Exo-Datei. Es hat natürlich keine grafische Oberfläche. Also es hat schon ein bisschen grafische Oberfläche, aber es hat irgendwie nicht, dass du da Push-Buttons machen kannst und irgendwie Fenster öffnen kannst. Und dieses Teil ist dann das erste Mal, wo die Kontrolle übergeben wird an irgendwie, was nicht von dem Hersteller von dem Laptop kommt. Und ist damit beschäftigt, irgendwie das auszuführen. Was dann genau passiert, da gibt es verschiedene Pfade. Da gibt es einmal den Pfad, den die meisten Distributionen nehmen. Das ist, es gibt dann einen Bootloader-Grab. Der ist derselbe Bootloader, der damals für BIOS-Systeme benutzt worden ist. Was der macht, ist, der sucht dann nach einem Körner in einem Linux-spezifischen Format, ELF. Da lädt er den Speichern für den aus. Irgendwie unsere eigene Theorie, wie das besser funktionieren sollte, ist, dass der Körner selbst in dem EFI-Format vorliegt. Das heißt, dass der Bootloader unnötig ist und irgendwie einen ganzen Teil der Kette rausgenommen wird, weil einfach irgendwie das EFI BIOS direkt in den Körner startet.
Gibt es da eine technische Einschränkung, die das verhindert, oder ist das sozusagen nur nicht umgesetzt?
Das gibt so philosophische Unterschiede zwischen uns und anderen. Die anderen halten es für viel wichtiger, die alten Systeme zu unterstützen mit derselben Technik und das Gleiche zu machen. Wir halten das für nicht so wichtig, weil sowieso alles heutzutage EFI ist und wir Software entwickeln sollten, weil wir das für die Zukunft tun und nicht für die Rechner.
Aber sagst du, das 32-Bit-Code kann auch 64-Bit-Code sein?
Ja, meistens ist es sogar 64-Bit-Code. 32-Bit-EFI ist eher die Ausnahme.
Das heißt, man hat jetzt sozusagen nochmal zwei Indirektionen dazwischen. Man hat sozusagen das erste EFI-Programm, das lädt einen Linux-spezifischen Bootloader, der nur dafür da ist, das Linux zu laden. Obwohl man im Prinzip zwei Stufen weglassen könnte. Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so ganz irrelevant für so Sicherheitsfragen. Gerade wenn man jetzt so an so Sicherungssysteme, Signierungen etc.
denkt. Ja, es geht ja um dieses ganze Thema Sacket-Boot. Sacket-Boot ist auch irgendwie etwas, was wir wichtig halten von der system-de-seite. Sacket-Boot wird irgendwann dargestellt, als ob das irgendwie Microsoft wäre, die da böse sind und irgendwie böse Spiegel mit Linux treiben wollen. Ich sehe das ganz anders irgendwie. Eigentlich war Microsoft da total nett zu uns und gibt uns eine Technik in die Hände, die wir für echte Vorteile nutzen können. Was Sacket-Boot letztendlich macht, ist, dass die im BIOS müssen hinterlegt sein, die Krypto-Schlüssel, mit denen die Binaries, diese EFI-Binaries, die man ausführen kann, signiert sind. Das BIOS, also die Firmware, weigert sich zu booten, was nicht mit einem gültigen Key signiert worden ist. Es ist eigentlich total tolle Technik. Per Default ist in der Firmware immer nur der Microsoft Key drin, damit man Windows booten kann. Oder auf Apple ist da sicher auch der Apple Key drin. Aber was eben nicht drin ist, ist der Linux Key. Deswegen glauben die Leute dann, sie sind nicht nett zu uns. Tatsächlich finde ich das aber total toll, weil das auch die Möglichkeit gibt, andersherum Microsoft oder Apple aus dem Boot-Prozess rauszuschmeißen, weil Microsoft war so nett und hat in die Spezifikation reingeschrieben, dass jedes BIOS, was das implementiert, was mit einem Windows-Stempel haben will, muss die Möglichkeit haben, dass man diese Keys austauschen kann. Das heißt, man kann sagen, okay, das ist ja toll. Oder nicht nur austauschen, sondern auch ergänzen kann, zusätzlich in der Hand machen kann. Das ist total toll, weil dann kann man sagen, okay, danke Microsoft, ich schmeiße jetzt einen Key raus, ich packe meinen Key da rein und boot jetzt nur noch meine Betriebssysteme, denen ich vertraue. Das kann dann entweder sein ein Fedora-Key oder es kann sogar sein einen privaten, den nur ich benutze. Und dann ist irgendwie dieses Feature, was viele Leute glauben, ist irgendwie was, um Linux zu ärgern, ist eigentlich total toll. Kann man umdrehen und dann mit Microsoft rausschmeißen und sicher sein, dass, wenn ich mal meinen Laptop irgendwo stehen lasse, dass er nicht einfach jemand hochbooted, einen USB-Stick bootet und irgendwas anderes reinpackt, weil das ist mit meinem Krokodil gesichert. Insofern, wir sehen das eigentlich immer, also unsere Top-Bit ist irgendwie ein großen Vorteil und irgendwie wollen die Betonungen darauf lesen, dass man diese Keys austauschen kann und dass wir es einfach machen sollten, dass diese Keys austauschbar sind. Also zum Beispiel die Idee wäre, das so hübsch zu machen, dass wenn du Linux installierst auf deinem Laptop, dass er dich fragt, willst du, dass der Key da reingepackt werden will, dass willst du den Windows-Key drin lassen, willst du den MacOS-Key drin lassen, oder soll ich die gleichzeitig raus schmeißen? Dann benutzt er einfach nur und sagt ja, nein, und dann ist der Key draußen. Dann hat man ein System, wo nichts anderes mehr reinkommt.
Kriegt man dann die Windows-Key wieder rein?
Ja, man kann meistens. Was die Kritiker von unseren Ideen immer betonen, ist, dass bei den meisten BIOS-Keyes das alles ein bisschen anders in der Menüführung. Und die haben dann Angst, dass man... Also damit man die Keys überhaupt rein oder rausnehmen kann, muss man erst mal in diesen EFI-Setup-Mode gehen. Und irgendwie, die meinen, das sei ein Problem, dass das nicht überall an der selben Stelle in den BIOS-Setups ist. Ich persönlich sehe das nicht so als großes Problem, weil irgendwie von einer CD oder von einem USB zu booten ist auch immer an einer vielen Schienenstelle im BIOS-Setup. Und wenn die Benutzer das kapiert haben, dass sie irgendwie von einem USB booten können, damit sie Fedora oder was auch immer installieren können, dann sollten sie auch in der Lage sein, kurz die Sackrboot auszuschalten für die Installation. Und einschalten kann man sie dann wieder automatisch von einem Installationsprogramm. Aber ja, also meistens kann man mit einem BIOS-Reset einfach die Keys wieder restaurieren. Und dann sind wieder die original Keys drin. Ja, irgendwie, ich glaube, dass Sackrboot eine gute Sache ist. Man muss sie nur irgendwie nutzen. Und wir haben auch selber so einen Teil geschrieben, das hieß früher mal Gummiboot. Jetzt heißt es SD-Boot. Das ist Teil von Systemd, also SD steht für Systemd. Das ist, manche Leute würden das einen Bootloader nennen, aber es ist explizit kein Bootloader. Nämlich, was es ist, ist einfach nur ein kleines EFI-Binary, was mit diesem EFI-Fab-Triver, also Datalsystem-Triver, nach anderen EFI-Binaries sucht. Sie sortiert nach einer Version, auf den Bildschirm bringt, dass man so was auswählen kann. Das heißt, es gibt hier einfach nur dieses Menü. Das heißt, es ist nicht wirklich ein Bootloader. Es hat kein Verständnis von dem, was es startet. Alles, was es macht, es startet andere EFI-Binaries.
Man braust einfach über verschiedene Bootfiles.
Genau. Und das ist ganz hübsch gemacht, weil du kannst es dann auch editieren, Kommandozahlen, Parameter angeben, und irgendwie zieht die Versionsnummer raus, einen schönen String und zeigt den hübschen Bildschirm an. Aber das ist irgendwie unser Ansatz für den ganzen Kram. Das heißt, wir haben keinen Bootloader, alles ist tatsächlich EFI. Wir akzeptieren, dass EFI irgendwie der Standard ist, mit dem heutzutage alles ist. Und machen das Beste daraus. Und versuchen irgendwie Sakeboot umzusetzen. Und versuchen irgendwie nicht mehr den Linux-spezifischen, komischen Format-Kram zu machen, sondern einfach zu sagen, ja, Linux ist jetzt auch ein EFI-Binary. Das ist das Ende der Geschichte. Aber wie auch immer. Wir sehen das halt so, die Zukunft macht alles einfacher. Die Leute von den meisten Distributionen sagen, ja, wir müssen aber auch noch diese und diese und diese Betriebssysteme unterstützen, wo du nur MBR-Boots hast und keine EFI-Boots hast und was weiß ich noch alles. Und deswegen brauchen wir Grub. Ich persönlich bin in Grub eins der schrecklichsten Projekte, die ich jemals berührt habe. Und ich sage das als jemand, der an Grub rumgehackt hat. Ja, und irgendwie, für mich persönlich ist Grub, es gibt keinen Grund mehr, Grub zu haben. Das war notwendig auf MBR-System, weil du eben nicht irgendwie das EFI-Umgebung hattest.
Aber das ist jetzt vorbei mit den MBR.
Für uns ist das vorbei.
Ja, nicht nur für euch. Gibt es überhaupt noch Computer, die ohne EFI kommen?
Die Server sind meistens ein bisschen konservativer. Die kommen auch alle mit EFI, aber die werden bei Laptops, weil Windows is required, immer EFI default an ist, bei den Servern, weil niemand Windows auf dem Server benutzt, diese Dinger nicht anpädigieren.
Verstehe, also könnte man einschalten, aber ist nicht.
Ich glaube, das wird inzwischen auch immer mehr eingeschaltet, aber es dauert noch ein bisschen. Also die Admins denken sich natürlich auch immer irgendwie, warum soll ich das jetzt einschalten?
Ja, aber Secure Boot wäre ja zum Beispiel ein guter Grund, das zu tun.
Ja, aber das ist schwierig den Leuten zu erklären. Also ich glaube, Secure Boot ist großartig und das ist echt was, was man unbedingt braucht und in die Köpfe von den Admins kriegen muss. Weil irgendwie da mit Snowden und so, da ist ja rausgekommen, dass dieses Facebook-Rechenzentrum von der NSA exploitet worden ist und dass die in den Leitungen drin waren und dann die Rechner mitgemacht haben, was immer sie wollten. Und deswegen hat Facebook dann irgendwie announced, dass sie irgendwie alle Leitungen verschwüsseln und die Betriebssysteme so absichern, dass sie nicht mehr vertrauen müssen den Leuten, die physikalisch Zugang haben zum Rechenzentrum. Und das ist eine total wichtige Sache. So muss ein Betriebssystem in der Zukunft designt sein, dass du das so sichergestaltest, dass tatsächlich physikalischer Zugriff auf die Maschine, auf der es läuft, es nicht komplett möglich macht, irgendwas damit zu machen. Und Circuit Boot ist ein Baustein dafür. Also das löst das Problem nicht ganz, wird es nie. Ganz lösen kann man das Problem nicht. Aber es kann zumindest diese Kette deutlich weitertreiben, weil man kann dann einfach sagen, mit ganz normaler Hardware, die man einfach im Laden kaufen kann, kann man halt sagen, dieser Rechner ist jetzt so eingestellt, dass er nur noch die Software, die ich geschrieben habe, da bootet. Oder Facebook kann sagen, nur noch die Software, die Facebook signiert hat, wird von der Maschine gebootet. Und wenn dann er irgendwie jemanden geschafft hat, in das Rechenzentrum einzubrechen und an den Server-Schränken vorbei läuft und irgendwelche Dinge reinsteckt, bringt ihm das gar nichts, weil auf dieses USB-Stick kann er nicht einfach einen Körner packen und das Ding hochbooten, weil es nicht signiert ist von Facebook. Und ich glaube, wenn das für Facebook gilt...
Auch beim Angriff von außen, wo es unter Umständen gelingt, in die Plattenbereiche reinzuschreiben, also wenn man exploit hat und in der Lage ist, sozusagen eigene Epifanze anzulegen...
Das wird dann beim Runtime gemerkt. Ist nicht signiert, mach ich nicht. Und ich glaube, so muss das Rechensteil in der Zukunft aussehen. Weil das wissen wir seit Snowden und so was, dass diese Eingriffe stattfinden. Und wenn Facebook das absichern kann und Google das absichert, dann ist das eine Sache. Ich glaube, dass wir alle Leute dazu bewegen müssen, das zu sichern. Und was am Chromebook zum Beispiel sehr interessant ist, ist, dass Chromebook der erste Rechner ist, der tatsächlich in die Hände von Konsumenten gekommen ist, der tatsächlich systematisch das Gleiche gemacht hat. Weil beim Chromebook ist auch das gesamte Betriebssystem signiert durch Google. Und es weigert sich, irgendwas anderes zu booten, was nicht von Google signiert ist. Das ist total toll, weil du kannst dieses Chromebook nehmen, du kannst es irgendjemandem anderen geben, du kannst sicher sein, er kann es nicht manipulieren und dir zurückgeben und du würdest es nicht merken. Also die haben ja irgendwie diesen Developer-Button da eingebaut, dass du das hacken kannst. Und was der macht, ist, der schaltet diese Kryptogramm aus und sorgt dafür, dass beim booten eine dicke große Meldung kommt, dieses Gerät ist im Developer-Modus, was für dich der Hinweis ist, dass es manipuliert worden ist.
Was dann aber auch wiederum bedeutet, dass man da nicht sein eigenes Linux installieren kann auf so einem Chromebook.
Na ja, kannst du ja, aber du kriegst halt immer diese Meldung. Aber das ist halt der Deal. Ich finde, grundsätzlich ist das irgendwie das System, wo wir hinmüssen. Wir brauchen so truste Systeme, wo das ganze Betriebssystem so designt ist, dass alles abgesichert ist. Bisher ist das noch nicht so vorgedrungen in alle Admins. Also Google und Facebook haben das verstanden und ein paar andere sicherlich auch. Aber letztendlich irgendwie die meisten Rechner, die heutzutage so in der Freiheit hier laufen, sind natürlich nicht so designt. Und da kriegt niemand mit, wenn irgendwie jemand es geschafft hat, das zu exploiten. Aber um zurückzukommen, ich glaube, das Hack-App-Boot ist der erste Teil davon, weil der sichert halt den Körner ab. Und eigentlich müssten wir das wirklich aktiv nutzen und irgendwie als unseren Vorteil sehen, dass wir Linux-Systemen absichern können und nicht als Gefahr sehen, wie Microsoft uns Spielchen spielt, weil man muss die Krise als Chance begreifen.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass der Körner jetzt gefunden wurde mit der richtigen Signaturversion und was nicht sonst noch die Anforderung war und das Linux initialisiert sich, macht sich jetzt über die Hardware her, checkt, was da ist. Ich will jetzt nicht so sehr viel Zeit im Körner verlieren, weil das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Feld, was wir hier bewusst aus dieser Sendung ausblenden. Mal schauen, vielleicht leg ich das ja nochmal nach, aber das bleiben wir erstmal beim System. Ab welchem Zeitpunkt wird es sozusagen aus der Perspektive von Systemd jetzt spannend? Wo fängt man dieses System langsam zu greifen?
Wenn der Körner sich ihn initialisiert hat, dann sucht er nach der, also im Allgemeinen, nicht notwendigerweise, aber im Allgemeinen ist das so aufgesetzt, bei allen großen Distros ist es, die sogenannte INIT-RD. Die INIT-RD steht für Initial RAM Disk. Ist ein bisschen falsch benannt, weil es gar keine RAM Disk mehr ist. Es ist nämlich ja was anderes. Aber diese INIT-RD, da sind sozusagen, ist etwas, was irgendwie so ein paar Programme, mit denen man die tatsächlich Festplatte finden kann, festchecken kann, mounten kann. Diese INIT-RD, die ist meistens an den Kernel drangeklebt. Und wenn sie nicht an den Kernel drangeklebt ist, dann ist sie neben dem Kernel in der zweiten Datei. Das heißt, Grub, wenn er den Kernel lädt, lädt er meistens nicht nur den Kernel, sondern auch die INIT-RD. Packt die beide in Speicher, der Kernel fängt dann an zu laufen, weiß, dass die im Speicher ist, die INIT-RD, und springt dann in den, also entpackt das und führt das aus. Diese INIT-RD läuft zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo Linux selbst vermutlich noch gar keine Idee hat von der Festbade. Also die poppt erst später auf. Da drin befindet sich dann so Code, mit dem Hardware geprobt wird und gewartet wird, bis die Festbade aufgetaucht ist. Wenn dann die Festbade aufgetaucht ist, passiert ein File-System-Check und dann geht es immer weiter. Dann wird die Transition ins Hauptsystem gemacht und so weiter. In Fedora und vielen Distros, ich glaube Suser und so was, aber nicht in Debian, in dieser INIT-RD läuft bereits System-D. Das heißt, das ist das erste Mal, wo der Kernel die Kontrolle an ein User-Space abgibt. Und da läuft schon System-D drin. Und das System-D da drin ist ganz minimal. Alles, was es macht, ist, auf die Festbarde zu warten, Firesystem check. Und, sobald die Festbarde da ist, mountet es die Festbarde und macht eine Transition, sodass diese gemountete Festbarde jetzt das neue Routerteilsystem wird und führt dann System-D aus, was in dem eigentlichen Festbarde drin ist. Das heißt, man hat da so ein Chainloading, wo, also ein Switchroute nennt man das auch, wo diese RAM-Disc zuerst läuft und dann wird umgeswitcht auf das echte. So einfach ist der ganze Kram nicht, weil man hat heutzutage so komplexen Storage-Kram. Das heißt, da ist unter Umständen, musst du da irgendwie DHCP machen, damit du NFS machen kannst, weil du von NFS buden willst. Oder du musst irgendwie Raid-Kram aufsetzen und mehrere Festbarde zusammenfügen, bevor du ins Routerteilsystem kommst. Oder du musst Ice-Gazzee machen oder was weiß ich noch alles. Krypto. Oder Krypto, ja. Insofern ist das nicht so ganz trivial. Das ist auch der Grund, warum wir da System-D drin laufen lassen, bei den meisten Distors. Weil wenn du Krypto machst, hast du ja auch mal wieder so eine komplexe Chain. Festbarde muss erst auftauchen. Wenn die Festbarde aufgetaucht ist, musst du Krypto aufsetzen. Wenn du Krypto aufgesetzt hast, musst du File-System-Check machen, musst du Mountain und so weiter sofort eine Transition machen. Das heißt, du hast die ganzen Abhängigkeitsbauen. Devian macht das allerdings noch nicht. Devian hat das alles selber gebaut. Wenn du mich brauchst, sollen die auch mal switchen, aber das ist denen überlassen. Die benutzen Systemd für das Hauptsystem, aber nicht für die InterdID. Ich würde in den Herstellern alles drüber switchen, weil es macht vieles einfacher. Aber das ist meine Meinung, was die Devian-Leute machen müssen. Natürlich die in ihrer Entscheidung. Wenn von dem Systemd, was in der InterdID liegt, und dem Systemd, was im Hauptsystem liegt, diese Transition gemacht wird, dieser Wechsel gemacht wird, wird der gesamte Zustand von Systemd serialisiert und dann von dem neuen wieder deserialisiert. Der Hintergrund ist der, dass wir irgendwie den Wissen wollen, nachdem das System hochgefahren ist, sind die erfolgreich, alle Dienste, die in der InterdID schon gelaufen sind, nämlich die Netzwerkkonfiguration für NFS, iSCSI-Services und so weiter, was ist da eigentlich passiert, sind die alle sauber gelaufen, damit du das hinterher wieder rauskriegen kannst. Dann, wenn die Systemd in dem Hauptsystem angefangen hat zu laufen, guckt es sich an, wo es eigentlich hinbooten soll. Und da gibt es dann so, entweder graphical.target oder multiuser.target heißt das. Das entspricht den alten Run-Level 4 und 5, nee, 3 und 5 von System 5. Das ist sozusagen die Definition, das ist das, wo wir hinbooten wollen.
Was meinst du jetzt mit dahinbooten?
Dahinbooten soll heißen, das drückt aus, was alles gestartet werden soll, bis der Boot als abgeschlossen verstanden werden soll. Das heißt, das ist zum Beispiel der grafische Login. Das ist der Druckerserver, wenn du das sagen willst, bla, bla, bla. Das heißt, wir, also an der Stelle gibt es dann irgendwie die multiuser.graphical, sind so zwei Standard, du kannst beliebige definieren, wie du willst, aber das steht dann halt drin, zieh das alles rein. So, und das guckt sich das System dann an und berechnet dann dynamisch daraus, was es alles jetzt genau starten muss. Das hängt natürlich immer ab, was es sich da genau berechnet von der verfügbaren Hardware oder was weiß ich, wie das System aufgesetzt worden ist. Weil irgendwie, wenn du dann irgendwie slash home von noch in einem Krypto mit noch LVM und was weiß ich noch hast, musst du natürlich was ganz anderes reinziehen, also wenn du das nicht hättest. Und dann, nachdem du das berechnet hast, hat, geht's los. Dann führt das einfach Stück für Stück aus. Dann startet er irgendwie erstmal die ganz wichtigen Dinge wie UDEV. Dann tauchen die ganzen Devices auf und startet der FS-Check. Nachdem die Filesystems gecheckt sind, macht er, mountet er die jeweils einzeln, wartet auf alle Datalsysteme, auf die er warten muss, also alle, die in ETCFS top gelistet sind. Wenn die alle aufgetaucht worden sind, geht er zum nächsten Schritt über und fängt an, die ganzen Dienste zu starten. Und irgendwann hat er etwas getan und dann hat er beschlossen, dass er fertig ist. Und dann läuft das Betriebssystem. Dann ist das System, die aber noch lange nicht fertig, irgendwie, das verschwindet dann nicht aus dem Speicher, weil dann läuft es die ganze Zeit weiter, um das System irgendwie am Laufen zu halten und alles zusammenzuhalten. Und insbesondere solche Dinge wie Socket Activation zu handeln. Das heißt, wenn irgendwann später mal dann irgendwas requestet wird, weil du hast irgendwie in der Oberfläche dein Audioprogramm gestartet und plötzlich muss irgendwie was Audiorelated ist noch nachgestartet werden, reagiert das Teil. Oder du steckst Hardware rein, dein Bluetooth-Dongel, plötzlich muss der Bluetooth-Dack hochgefahren werden. Dafür läuft SystemD dann die ganze Zeit weiter und merkt sich ganz genau, was da alles läuft. Mit SystemD kannst du dich dann auch kommunizieren, herauskriegen, was ist eigentlich los, was ist gefailt, was war erfolgreich usw. Und dann, richtig aktiv wird es dann erst wieder beim Runterfahren, wo dann das inverse berechnet wird. Das heißt, das Ziel ist dann irgendwie, alles zu beenden und irgendwie ein letztes Binary auszuführen, was den Strom ausmacht. Und daraus berechnet SystemD dann sozusagen in inversen Transaction, wo irgendwie alles, was jetzt läuft, gestoppt wird, in einer richtigen Reihenfolge, weil irgendwie, was weiß ich, man sollte einen Dienst, der DEVOS benötigt, nicht nach DEVOS beenden, sondern vor DEVOS beenden.
Also ein Unwinding der ganzen DEVOS. Also im Prinzip gibt es für SystemD grob vier wichtige Phasen. Die erste Phase, die in gewisser Linie noch optional ist, weil das hängt von der Distribution ab, ob das dann auch wirklich eingebaut wird, ist sozusagen als Helfershelfer des Kernels, um überhaupt erst mal die Kernel-Level-Geschichten alle an den Start zu kriegen, weil Zugriff auf Festplatten mit kompensierten Crypto-Stacks etc.
In dieser Init-RD-Phase geht es explizit darum, das Root-Dateilsystem zu finden. Das ist die Priorität und das ist das Einzige, wodurch es definiert wird. Und alles andere, was es tut, ist es nur, um dieses Ziel zu erreichen.
Aber auch an der Stelle hilft sozusagen dieser Graf von Abhängigkeiten, der irgendwo abgelegt ist. Sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal darauf eingehen. Dann, wenn das abgeschlossen ist, kommt dann der eigentliche, ich würde es mal System Start-up nennen. Also Boot ist für mich mehr so der Körner.
Wir nennen das immer irgendwie, innerDAD ist der erste Teil, Early Boot und Late Boot. Und innerDAD ist halt alles, wo er irgendwie nur das Router-Teilsystem sucht. Early Boot ist dann alles, was darauf unüberfolgt und was bis zu dem Punkt geht, wo er anfängt, die ganz normalen Demons wie Apache und Drucker Server und sowas, wo er anfängt, die zu starten, das ist der Early Boot. Und da macht er alles Mögliche, da konfiguriert er System Controls, konfiguriert er allen möglichen komischen Kleinkramen, irgendwie Binary Formats, irgendwie alles, was man so braucht. Und dann der Late Boot ist halt irgendwie Apache starten, Kops starten, was weiß ich noch, alles starten. Und alles danach ist dann Runtime. Also innerDAD, Early Boot, Late Boot, Runtime. Dann hast du Shutdown zum wieder runterfahren. Dann gibt es da auch noch zwei Phasen, oder drei Phasen sozusagen. Weil was wir tatsächlich machen, was ganz neu war in innerDAD, was niemand vor uns gemacht hat, ist, wenn wir wieder runterfahren, dann hat man das Problem. Irgendwie die Festplatte, wenn die jetzt auf LVM ist und was weiß ich noch, allem Komplizierten, dann kann man ja nicht einfach die Festplatte unmounten. Weil die Binary's, die man laufen hat, sind ja von der Festplatte, die man versucht anzumounten. Also das ist ja ein Cyclic Dependency wieder. Was machst du denn da? Und was wir dann in ein System eingebaut haben, ist, dass wir wieder zurück in die innerDAD wechseln. Das heißt, diese innerDAD, die wird benutzt, um am Anfang des Route-Mediums zu finden, aufzusetzen und da reinzuwechseln, bleibt dann liegen im Speicher, aber komplett passiv. Dann läuft das System, fährt weiter hoch, blablabla, läuft für drei Tage oder so was, wird dann runtergefahren. Und dann wechselt das Hauptsystem wieder zurück in die innerDAD. Und alles, was die innerDAD dann machen muss, ist wieder das Route-Datarsystem auseinanderzunehmen, also anzumounten, irgendwie Raid zu sinken und auszuschalten, Eiskassi runterzufahren, irgendwie Netzwerk wegzumachen, wenn das irgendwie Netzwerk-Krams war, sodass am Schluss nichts mehr gemoutet ist und alles im sauberen Zustand ist und alles gesynkt ist auf die Festweite. Und dann findet der letzte Teil statt, wo tatsächlich irgendwie Strom ausgeschaltet wird. Aber ja, kompliziertes Ding, wo man erst, wie gesagt, drei große Phasen zum Hochfahren hat. Und tatsächlich sind es, sagen wir mal, eins, zwei, drei Phasen zum Runterfahren wieder. Also das ist nämlich die normale Shutdown-Phase, wo die ganzen normalen Dienste runtergefahren werden. Dann kommt eine spezielle Phase, wo alles beendet wird, was nicht sowieso schon sauber beendet wurde. Das ist so eine Killing Spree, wo man einfach mal so rumgeht und sagt, was ist denn noch da?
Was läuft noch?
Ich will nicht wissen, warum du da bist. Du hättest hier nicht sein sollen, aber ich mach dich jetzt trotzdem weg, weil ich muss runterfahren. Dann killen wir alles das. Und das ist die Killing Spree, die zweite Phase. Und die dritte Phase ist dann zurück in der EndetID, wo die Routerteils dem weggemacht werden.
Also alle haben sozusagen Zeit, sich gemächlich zu beenden, aber wer dann halt immer noch da sitzt und an seinem Lutschner...
Wer ignoriert, dass man ihn freundlich aufgefordert hat, der wird dann einfach brutalstmöglich getillt.
Wie definiert man denn nun dieses System mit diesen ganzen komplizierten Grafen und Abhängigkeiten? Das klingt ja komplex.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen komplexer, als wir das gerne hätten, aber ich glaube, die Komplexität ist notwendig. Wir haben das Grafen-Theorie, wenn man mal Informatik studiert hat, muss man das auch besuchen, glaube ich. Zumindest habe ich das besucht, bei den Mathematikern. Grafen-Theorie ist immer so etwas, wo man so Nodes hat und die haben so Verbindungen. Die sind gerichtet oder ungerichtet. Das ist letztendlich, was wir da machen. Die Nodes, also die Knoten, die nennen wir UNIX-Einheiten. Davon gibt es verschiedene Typen. Ein Unit ist z.B. alles Services, alle Dienste, so etwas wie Apache, Kubs, was weiß ich noch alles. Das ist jeweils ein Dienst und damit eine Unit. Es gibt noch andere Units. Units können auch Devices sein. Units können Mountpoints sein und so weiter und so fort. Das sind alles halt irgendwo zwischen, wo wir die Abhängigkeiten ausdrücken. Insgesamt gibt es, glaube ich, inzwischen neun Unit-Typen, aber vielleicht erzähle ich unfug. Ich habe da selber einen Überblick verloren. Und zwischen diesen Units gibt es dann Abhängigkeiten. Und dann gibt es Abhängigkeiten wie Requires und Wants. Das heißt irgendwie, ich benötige was anderes. Requires heißt, ich benötige das andere. Und wenn das andere nicht fähig ist, hochzufahren, dann möchte auch ich failen. Also wenn das eine failt, fail auch ich. Wants ist eine weichere Variante davon. Das heißt, so viel wie, ich will das andere haben. Wenn aber das andere nicht geht, ist mir egal. Ich will trotzdem gestartet werden. Und dann gibt es noch ein paar andere, die sind nicht so spannend. Aber solche Abhängigkeiten gibt es. Und dann gibt es noch Ordering-Abhängigkeiten, also die Reihenfolge bestimmen. Weil, wenn du irgendwas anderes willst, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass du auch unbedingt danach gestartet werden willst. Das kann auch heißen, ich will das andere haben und es kann irgendwann auftauchen. Aber es ist egal, wann das passiert. Das heißt, in Systemd sind tatsächlich diese Notwendigkeit, ich brauche was anderes und ich möchte nach was anderem gestartet werden. Also Reihenfolge und Requirement Dependencies. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das in Deutsch nennen würde. Notwendigkeit ist ein bisschen zu hart ausgedrückt.
Notwendige Abhängigkeiten.
Das ist eben nicht notwendig, weil once ist eben nicht so hart.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Also das heißt, diese beiden Arten von Abhängigkeiten. Sind in diesem Graph drin und die sind komplett orthogonal, wie der Mathematiker sagen würde. Das heißt, das eine sagt nichts über das andere aus und das andere nichts über das eine. Du kannst eine once-Abhängigkeit haben mit einer Reihenfolge, du kannst eine ohne Reihenfolge haben, aber du kannst auch eine Reihenfolge ohne eine once-Abhängigkeit haben. Das ist komplett dir überlassen, was du auch häufig willst. Weil du willst irgendwie so sagen, ja, diese zwei Services, wenn sie zusammenlaufen, zum Beispiel MySQL und Apache. Apache braucht keinen MySQL, absolut nicht. Aber vermutlich hast du auf deinem Apache eine Webseite laufen, die MySQL brauchen. Das heißt, wenn beide zusammenlaufen gelassen werden, dann sollte Apache nach MySQL gelassen werden. Aber nicht wirklich. Es braucht nicht MySQL wirklich. Das heißt, da hast du diesen Abhängigkeitsbau. Und das System, das du dann einfach machst, es werden ein paar Punkte markiert, wo die gestartet werden. Es wird genau ein Punkt, also eine Unit markiert, ein Knoten in diesem Abhängigkeitsbaum. Dann verfolgen wir diese Abhängigkeitspfeile zwischen diesen Knoten und nehmen alle weiteren Units dazu, die benötigt werden. Das ist dann der erste Teil. Dann wissen wir schon mal, was wir starten sollten. Dann gibt es allerdings ein bisschen Komplexität da drin, weil Units können auch miteinander konflikten. Das heißt, wenn du zwei Syslog-Implementationen drauf hast, R-Syslog und Syslog-NG, dann konflikten die miteinander. Weil es können nicht beide gleichzeitig diesen Socket, auf den der Traffic reinkommt, also der Long-Traffic reinkommt, können nicht beide gleichzeitig machen. Das heißt, sie müssen miteinander konflikten. Das heißt, dann kommt so eine Phase, wo wir versuchen, diesen Abhängigkeitsbaum dem Sinn zu geben. Das heißt, dafür zu sorgen, dass irgendwie once and requires alles erfüllt wird, aber andererseits Konflikt auch. Das heißt, wenn irgendwie was required wird, was aber dann von was anderem konfliktet wird, dann kann man halt Widersprüche ausdrücken, dann muss es bereinigt werden und reduziert werden, sodass diese Notwendigkeit Sinn macht. Das ist der eine Teil. Und dann kommt der zweite Teil, wo dieser selbe Subbaum, den wir jetzt bestimmt haben, auf Zyklenfreiheit getestet wird. Weil, jetzt haben wir immer noch diese Reihenfolgeteile, und da kann zum Beispiel drin vorkommen, Apache möchte vor MySQL gestartet werden, aber MySQL möchte auch vor Apache gestartet werden. Das kann man natürlich nicht machen, weil das ist einfach logisch unmöglich. Das heißt, das System muss das erkennen und muss damit eine Lösung finden. Die Lösung sieht dann so aus, sie ist nicht besonders geistreich, die Lösung ist einfach, ich schmeiße eins raus und lasse das andere drin. Das heißt, es ist immer noch besser, Apache zu starten und meistens rauszulassen als nichts zu starten. Oder irgendwie nicht zu wagen, zu booten. Das geht ja dann auch nicht. Das ist das, was das System da macht und berechnet. Am Schluss hat es dann irgendwie einen reduzierten Abhängigkeitsbaum, der zyklenfrei ist, und den führt es dann einfach nur ganz stupide aus. Dann nimmt es sich die erste Unit, wo alle Ordering-Abhängigkeiten erfüllt sind, führt sie aus.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Konfiguration hat ja einen extrem deklarativen Charakter.
Genau, das ist sehr wichtig.
Man sagt ja eigentlich genau das, wie man es auch meint. Das sind die Bedingungen, die erfüllt sein müssen. Ich überlasse dem System sozusagen die Entscheidung, was daraus folgt.
Ganz genau.
Während man vorher eigentlich diese ganze Geschichte von Hand gemacht hat. Das Prinzip genauso wie mit traditionellen, imperativen Programmiersprachen, wo man den Prozessor an der Hand führen muss. Jetzt machst du das im Vergleich zu deklarativen Programmiersprachen, wo man auch sagt, das ist das, was rauskommen soll. Jetzt entscheide mal selber, welcher reinfällt.
Das ist ein absolut essenzieller Punkt. Man gibt nicht tatsächlich eine Ausführlogik für den Prozessor an, sondern man sagt einfach nur, das sind die Abhängigkeiten, krieg du es raus. Das war wie gesagt unser Hauptkritikpunkt mit Upstart gewesen. Upstart hat das wieder genau die Events an die Events geklebt und du musstest das machen als Admin oder als Developer oder sogar als User. Und wir sagen, sag mir nur was los ist und ich versuche dir das minimal daraus zu reduzieren, was irgendwie Sinn macht und ich sage dir, wenn irgendwo ein Fehler ist. Aber natürlich, das ist ja schon komplexer, das so zu machen. Ich glaube, das muss man so machen. Irgendwie, wenn man dieses Problem lösen will mit Abhängigkeiten, dann kommt man nicht drumherum als dieses Problem.
Man kriegt ja im Prinzip die Fehler auch schon vorher genannt, oder? Weil diese Überprüfung ist ja nichts, was dann zur Laufzeit festgestellt wird, oder?
Das hängt schon sehr von der Laufzeit ab, weil nur bei der Laufzeit weiß man, ob jetzt dieses USB-Festball aufgetaucht ist oder nicht.
Ach so, ja klar. Aber man sieht im Prinzip schon vorher, ob der Plan überhaupt aufgeht oder ob man schon mal grundsätzlich einen Fehler hat.
Leider ist es aber nicht so einfach zu verstehen. Das ist ein Problem. Ich weiß noch nicht, wie wir das einfach machen können. Also zum Beispiel die Zyklenfreiheit. Wenn wir feststellen, dass da ein Zyklus ist, das heißt irgendwie Apache will MySQL haben, MySQL will Apache, dann schreiben wir das in die Logs raus und sagen, ja, hier ist ein Zyklus, der geht so. Das vor dem, das vor dem, das vor dem. Und dann bist du am Anfang wieder, wo du am Schluss bist. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie man es besser ausdrücken kann, als wir das tun. Aber ich kann nur feststellen, dass wir ganz viele Bugreports kriegen, wo Leute denken, ich sehe das hier, was soll ich tun? Und dann denke ich, ja, die haben uns bemüht. Du hast da was falsch ausgedrückt, das ist unmöglich zu befolgen. Und du musst das fixen, weil die Leute sagen, ja, in System 5.init war das aber nicht ein Problem. Haben sie auch recht, weil System 5.init hat sich für sowas nie interessiert. System 5.init, da hast du gesagt, starte das, da hat er das gestartet, starte das irgendwie. Hattest du nie das Konzept, musstest du nie mit dem Problem dich auseinandersetzen, dass es so zyklische Probleme gibt.
Das mag ja dann sogar auch funktioniert haben, weil sich die Software dann aus welchen Gründen auch immer miteinander ausgekäst hat, aber es ist halt nicht wirklich das, was man haben wollte.
Ja, das ist dieser Abhängigkeitsbaum, den wir da machen. Es ist relativ komplex leider deswegen, aber eigentlich ganz schön. Und er hat dann auch noch so Logiken, dass irgendwie, wir haben uns ja irgendwas berechnet am Anfang. Und dann taucht irgendwas auf plötzlich. Eine Festbar, äh, nicht eine Festbar, aber ein Stück Hardware, was wir nicht erwartet haben. Irgendwie eine Bluetooth-Dongel taucht auf. Und das hat dann plötzlich, sorgt dann dafür, dass noch andere Sachen gestartet werden müssen, die in einer initialen Berechnung gar nicht drin waren. Also das heißt, plötzlich musst du den Bluetooth-Dag starten, weil irgendwann die USB-Bluetooth-Hardware-Ding aufgedauert ist. Und das heißt, dann muss man dieses Berechnete dann noch merge. Das heißt, du hast einmal diesen minimalen Baum, hast den zweiten minimalen Baum, musst du erstmal testen, ob dieser zweite Baum dem ersten wieder spricht. Und dann, wenn du festgestellt hast, dass er nicht widerspricht, mergest du die beiden und lässt nur noch den gemeinsamen, der den oder ausführst. Ja, das ist die Transaktionslogik, die wir in dem System drin haben, weil wir sagen halt irgendwie, ja, starte das, aber das wird als ganzes failen irgendwie, wenn es etwas widerspricht, was schon gestartet worden ist. Aber letztendlich ist es noch viel komplizierter als das, weil wir dann außerdem noch diese ganzen Modis einbauen mussten. Also wir sagen, okay, aber das, was ich jetzt reincue, ist eigentlich das wirklich Wichtige. Und wenn da vorher was reingecued war, was meinem widerspricht, dann schmeißt du bitte das Alte raus anstatt des Neuen. Wenn wir runterfahren zum Beispiel, ist das essentiell. Weil wenn wir beim Runterfahren sagen, ja, dein Dependency-Tree hat leider Cycles, ich kann jetzt nicht runterfahren, dann freuen die Leute das nicht besonders. Insofern muss man an der Stelle dann sagen, okay, das ist jetzt das, was gilt, und alles andere ist, was rausfliegen muss, wenn es Cycles hat.
Aber trotz aller Schwierigkeiten, was man am Ende erhält, ist eine Systemdefinition, die vor allem zu jedem Zeitpunkt konsistent ist.
Das ist die Hoffnung, ja.
Im Idealfall, Fehler können immer passieren, aber im Prinzip, es gibt einen Plan, wie das System gerade ist.
Und wie es dahin gekommen ist.
Wie es dahin gekommen ist und wie man es da auch wieder wegbekommt. Und wenn man jetzt vor allem manuelle Maßnahmen, wir hatten das ja schon, fahr mal einen Dienst runter, wegen, keine Ahnung, dann ist sofort klar, welche Prozesse sind das, was muss denen gesagt werden und was sind unter Umständen andere Dinge, die dann auch betroffen sind in irgendeiner Form, weil sie darauf dependen, sodass man sozusagen diese ganze Kette immer komplett bedient.
Ganz genau.
Häufig ist es ja so, dass man sich das einfach selber dann nicht mehr erinnert. Wenn ich in meinem Webserver rumfuhr, werke und da irgendwas hoch und runter fahre, dann merke ich dann so, warte mal, das hätte ich jetzt vielleicht besser nicht tun sollen.
Das, was irgendwie schade an der ganzen Sache ist, ist, wie schnell diese Abhängigkeitsnetze tatsächlich komplex werden. Weil wir haben da was eingebaut. Wir haben einen ganzen Satz von Debugging-Tools, damit man mit dieser Abhängigkeitssache auch umgehen kann. Und eins davon, von diesen Debugging-Tools generiert eine mit GraphVis, das ist so ein Tool, mit dem man so Grafen plotten kann, so eine vollständige Grafik, die alle Abhängigkeiten im System plotte, die beim Booten irgendwie in Consideration genommen werden, also irgendwie beachtet werden.
Macht bestimmt eine gute Wandtapete.
Ja, leider ja. Leider ist es so groß, dass es sinnlos ist zu tun. Also wir haben das Tool jetzt drin und die einzige Art und Weise, wie man das nutzen kann, ist, indem man sagt, irgendwie reduziere mir das auf diese Unit und alle Abhängigkeiten, die drei Level weg davon sind oder sowas. Weil der gesamte Baum, kannst du gerne generieren, ist so groß, dass es total sinnlos ist.
Ich meine, das ist ja das beste Argument, warum man das dem Computer überlassen sollte, weil im Prinzip ist das ja genau das, was man sonst im Kopf haben müsste.
Ganz genau. Ja, also irgendwie, wir versuchen es auch irgendwie runterzubrechen, damit die Leute halt irgendwie nicht wirklich in den ganzen Abhängigkeiten denken müssen, haben wir immer so Punkte definiert in den Bäumen, wo die Leute sich reinhaken können. Das heißt zum Beispiel, wenn man im Late Boot gestartet werden muss als Default Service, muss man Null angeben eigentlich, weil wir sagen einfach, okay, wenn du nichts angibst, heißt das so viel wie, du bist ein ganz normaler, langweiliger Service, du wirst jetzt im Late Boot gestartet und bist beim Runterfahren in der ersten Phase runtergefahren, Ende der Geschichte. Die Leute können es dann von da an beliebig kompliziert machen. Können zum Beispiel sagen, ich möchte mit dem Early Boot gestartet werden und dann geben wir ihnen so ein paar Punkte, so ein paar Hooks an, wo sie irgendwie, können sich davor sortieren, können sich dahinter sortieren, können sich dazwischen sortieren und solche Dinge.
Wo wie ich will gestartet werden, wenn DNS läuft oder so.
Ganz genau, solche Dinge. Oder irgendwie, ich möchte gestartet werden, wenn das aufgetaucht ist und das aufgetaucht ist und dann möchte ich aber vor dem und dem gestartet werden oder sowas Ähnliches. Und wenn der und der failt, dann möchte ich auch failen. Und wenn dieser Hardware wieder verschwindet, möchte ich wieder beendet werden und was weiß ich noch alles. Aber also die Idee ist irgendwie, das dependency-Kram, das kann kompliziert werden. Wir versuchen, das irgendwie einfach zu machen, indem wir irgendwie implizit gute Defaults versuchen, dafür zur Verfügung zu stellen. Und für viele Fälle reicht das aus. Und für die anderen Fälle irgendwie das so generisch machen, dass, wenn die Leute wissen, welche Hooks, Points es gibt, sie nicht wirklich explizit die Abhängigkeit hinschreiben müssen, sondern nur ganz generisch sagen können, ich will danach und davor gestartet werden.
Jetzt seid ihr seit fünf Jahren dabei, sagt ihr. Und seid aber gut beschäftigt sozusagen mit dem Projekt, ne?
Ja, das Projekt hat kein Ende. Es ist so ein Projekt, wo man nicht sagen kann, wenn wir das geimplementiert haben, ist es fertig. Also irgendwie Donald Knus hat bei Tech gesagt, wenn er das implementiert, dann ist Tech fertig. Und jetzt ist es seit 92 fertig oder so. Aber das ist definitiv nicht so. Awahi zum Beispiel ist ein Projekt, das war fertig. Irgendwann habe ich die Spezifikationen implementiert. Das war es. Seitdem mache ich Maintenance dafür. Und mache ich nicht besonders gut, aber ich mache es irgendwie manchmal. Aber ich muss auch nicht viel machen, weil der Code ist einfach da und das Protokoll verändert sich nicht mehr. Und es tut, was es tut. Aber Systemd ist natürlich nicht so. Systemd ist in unseren Augen etwas, was wachsen muss, wie die IT-Technik insgesamt wächst. Irgendwie muss es verfolgen, wie die Computer sich fortentwickeln. Wenn Computer jetzt plötzlich irgendwie, was weiß ich, mit dem Hotplug-Kram irgendwie. System5Init hätte sich eigentlich auch mit dem Hotplug-Kram an das Dynamische gewöhnen müssen. Hat es aber natürlich nie gemacht. Aber für uns gilt halt irgendwie.
Neue Busse, neue Architekturen.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen der Treiber, Low-Level. Das interessiert uns nicht mehr so viel. Aber wenn irgendwie was anders gemacht werden muss, dann müssen wir das irgendwie, was heißt das, RF-Kill-Support, wenn plötzlich alle Laptops RF-Kill haben und das irgendwie ein blöder Schalter ist, dann sagen wir, okay, dann muss das wohl ins System rein. Dann machen wir das einfach. Und wie sich die Welt halt so ändert. Es gibt natürlich irgendwie, es gibt wichtigere Dinge in der Mitte, wo das einen größeren Einfluss hat. Aber irgendwie für uns ist das so. Es wird noch weiterentwickelt. Und wir haben eine ganze Menge auf unserer Liste, woran wir gerade arbeiten. Also eine von den Sachen, von den größeren Sachen ist zum Beispiel Networking. Wir haben da so einen Dienst, der heißt Network Day. Der ist noch relativ neu, aber schon viele Distros haben wir tatsächlich adoptet. Es geht darum, um Netzwerkkonfiguration. Weil irgendwie für uns war immer, Netzwerkkonfiguration muss irgendwie total, es muss aber da sein. Heutzutage gibt es kaum Rechner, die nicht irgendwie im Netzwerk sind. Ob ich mein Handy angucke, oder ob ich dein MacBook hier angucke, oder wenn ich meinen Kühlschrank heutzutage angucke. Ich habe keinen modernen Kühlschrank. Alle Geräte, alle Laptops können das fast. Also überhaupt Nodes, Embedded Nodes, Server sowieso. Alle können irgendwie Netzwerk. Und wir haben uns überlegt, dass es irgendwie nicht so toll ist, was es da momentan für Optionen gab. Weil alle Distros haben irgendwie ihre Netzwerkskrippen gehabt, irgendwie Debian, EF, Updown und Red Hat, seine Networking-Skripte. Und alle waren nicht besonders gut. Also, das ist freundlich ausgedrückt. Und können nur irgendwie den ganz einfachen Kram. Und können nicht auf Hopplock richtig reagieren. Und du kannst nicht irgendwie so generischen Kram ausdrücken, wo du irgendwie eine Konfiguration schreibst und die dann automatisch appliziert ist auf was auch immer. Und dann gab es am anderen Ende, da gab es Network Manager. Network Manager ist ein kompliziertes Beast. Es kommt ursprünglich von den Desktop-Leuten. Und macht D-Bos, was weiß ich noch, einem. Und den Teil finde ich auch ganz sympathisch. Aber die Idee ist halt irgendwie, es kommt von den Desktop-Leuten, und man kann es halt klicky-klicky machen und es reagiert tatsächlich auf Dinge. Wir haben aber unsere Probleme mit Network Manager, weil auch wenn es irgendwie konzeptuell in unsere Richtung geht, ist es schlimm in vielerlei Hinsicht. Da sage ich als jemand, der bei Red Hat arbeitet, wo auch Network Manager herkommt. Aber nach all den Jahren, solange wie Network Manager schon existiert, ist es irgendwie, und Red Hat versucht es gerade, auf den Server zu pushen, ist es irgendwie nie da angekommen. Und die Serverleute, die hassen es auch. Na gut, sie mögen auch Systemlinien nicht, aber ich glaube, viele Serverleute mögen es doch, Network Manager noch weniger als die Systemlinien mögen. Oder ich glaube, na gut, so wie ich es sehe...
Du meinst, ihr gewinnt den Popularity-Contest.
Ich sage ja, der Network Manager gewinnt den Unpopularity-Contest. Okay, genau so weit ich das. Ich glaube, die meisten Admins haben es sogar arrangiert mit Systemd oder sogar die Vorteile inzwischen eingesehen. Ich würde es gar nicht so negativ sagen.
Auf jeden Fall versucht ihr sozusagen das Prinzip von, wie stelle ich Verbindungen zum Netz her, auch auf andere Beine zu stellen.
Weil wir uns überlegt haben, es muss auch mal wieder anders funktionieren, weil wir wollen etwas, was das Problem vollständig löst. Das heißt auch in der Internet-ID. Network Manager zum Beispiel kann in dieser Internet-ID nicht laufen, weil das ist, was wir eh noch alles haben. Wir sagen, das Netzwerk muss so früh verfügbar sein, weil du willst NFS-Boots, Eiskassi-Boots, was weiß ich noch alles Boots machen. Und da muss auch schon eine Netzwerk-Zuverfügung stehen. Und was anderes, was wir wollen, ist, dieses ganze Konzept von statischen Netzwerk-Verbindungen ist irgendwie ein Konzept, das ist aus den 90ern. Heutzutage muss in unseren Augen Netzwerk-Interfaces aufpoppen können und weggehen können. Zu jeder Zeit. Und man muss dem System in einer sinnvollen Art und Weise mitteilen, was es damit machen kann. Und das geht dann so weit, dass in Network-Deal kannst du so Dinge ausdrücken wie, dies ist eine Netzwerkkonfiguration, appliziere sie auf alles, was diesen Regeln entspricht. Das kann zum Beispiel ganz generisch heißen, appliziere sie auf alles, was Ethernet ist. Du kannst aber auch viel spezifischer sein und sagen, expliziere es auf Ethernet, was den Interface-Namen hat oder expliziere es auf Ethernet mit dieser Mac-Adresse. Und wir coveren eine ganze Menge von verschiedenen Transporttechniken, so etwas Bridging und Bonding, wie sie alle heißen, 500.000 verschiedene Tunnel, die Linux kennt und Abhängigkeiten wieder dazwischen. Das heißt, du kannst, weil Network-Deal so generisch ist und weil es immer diese ganzen Aggregate-Dinger bauen kann, kannst du halt so tolle Dinge ausdrücken wie, immer wenn ein Ethernet-Device auftaucht, packe es zu diesem Bridge-Interface hinzu. Kreiere aber erstmal das Bridge-Interface. Und wenn das Bridge-Interface weggeht, wenn alle Devices weg sind, mache ich auch wieder das Bridge-Interface weg. Und wenn das Bridge-Interface auftaucht, machst du darauf eine IP-Adresse. Das heißt, da kannst du dir mit so einer einzigen Datei, mit einer einzigen Konfigurationsdatei in Network-D ein Embedded-Device bauen, wo, sobald du eine USB Ethernet-Karte reinsteckst, wird es zu einer USB-Bridge. Wenn du zwei reinsteckst, werden die Automate verbunden. Das kannst du alles mit den ganzen Alten nicht machen, weil der Network-Manager würde sagen, hey, hier ist ein neues Network-Device aufgetaucht. Bing, konturier es mal hier. Und sonst, wenn du nichts konturierst, bleibe ich einfach hängen.
Und auch so VPNs, die dann automatisch entstehen.
VPNs covern wir momentan nicht. Network-D covert momentan nicht alles. Weil unser Fokus war ganz klar auf Embedded, auf die Internet-D, auf Server-Kram und Cloud-Kram. Was wir nicht covern, ist tatsächlich der Kram, wo Network-Manager richtig gut ist. Nämlich Desktop-Kram. Das liegt unter anderem heißt das, dass wir keine VPNs machen momentan. Und dass wir kein WLAN machen. Und was ein Riesenproblem ist. Bevor wir WLAN machen, wird das niemand benutzen auf seinem Laptop. Also ich benutze es auf meinem Laptop, aber ich benutze Network-Manager fürs WLAN, Network-D für den ganzen Rest. Aber wir glauben irgendwie, dass die Art und Weise, wie Network-D funktioniert, wirklich substanziell besser ist als alles andere, wo er da ist. Weil du kannst plötzlich diese generischen Logiken ausdrücken. Und du hast plötzlich das erste Mal so ein Network-System, wo du Dinge zusammenstecken kannst, komplett dynamisch. Und wo du wieder deklarativ sagst, ja dieses ist das Network-Interface, mach mit dem Network-Interface dieses. Mach das in das Bonding rein. Mach das Bonding in das Bridging rein. Und du kannst das sagen für beliebig viele Instanzen davon. Du kannst das sagen, auch wenn es jetzt nicht auftaucht, wenn es irgendwann auftaucht, machst du das. Und reconfigure den ganzen Scheiß. Ja, das ist irgendwie was, woran wir gerade arbeiten. Und das ist auch ein riesiges Projekt dafür, das passiert ununterbrochen was Neues in der Netzwerkwelt. Das müssen wir alles nachrüsten. Und wir haben auch noch so viel zu tun, weil wir zum Beispiel kein Wifi können oder sowas. Und eigentlich wollen wir das auch irgendwie. Und auch weil wir das irgendwie versuchen, alles konsequenter zu lösen mit Networkd. Was Network Manager früher gemacht hat, ist, die haben Dinge zusammengestärkt. Also zum Beispiel DHCP. Da benutzt Network Manager diese ISC-DHCP-Implementation. Nun ist es aber so, also es ist wieder was, wo uns vermutlich NIH vorgeworfen wird von vielen, dass DHCP eins der trivialsten Protokolle ist, die du machen kannst. Also DHCP für jene, die es nicht wissen, ist wie sich ein Rechner, wenn du ihn mal netzwerks anschließt, eine IP-Adresse holt, in meisten Fällen. Und DHCP ist aber eins der trivialsten Protokolle, die es überhaupt gibt. Weil es geht so, ich schicke ein Paket raus, sag, hey, ich hätte vielleicht eine IP-Adresse gerne. Kann mir jemand helfen? Jemand sagt, hey, hier, ich könnte dir diese anbieten. Und dann geht es, ja, die will ich. Und dann sagt er, hier hast du sie. Das ist ungefähr das ganze Protokoll. Mehr ist da wirklich nicht drin. Während des laufenden Betriebs passiert da gar nichts mehr. Sobald du deinen Lease hast, gilt das. Und irgendwie, wir haben uns überlegt, okay, das ist ja total toll, warum benutze ich jetzt ISC, DHCP dafür? Insbesondere, weil DHCP existiert nicht im luftleeren Raum. Es gibt noch eine ganze andere Menge von Protokollen, die related dazu sind. Zum Beispiel IPv4-LL ist ein anderes Protokoll. Das ist IPv4-linked-local-addressing. Das geht darum, dass wenn du keinen DHCP-Server hast, wie die sich automatisch IP-Adressen suchen. Und du musst jetzt IPv4-LL mit DHCP eigentlich integrieren. Weil du willst sowas haben wie irgendwie DHCP, versuchst du zuerst, wenn das nicht geht, gehst du IPv4-LL. Und dann versuchst du aber immer mal wieder DHCP zu machen, um vielleicht doch DHCP zu kriegen, wenn irgendjemand der DHCP-Server wieder hochgefahren ist und solche Dinge. Das heißt, du hast da plötzlich irgendwie die ganzen eigentlich nominell unabhängigen Protokolle, die plötzlich alle zusammengehören. Weil die sind irgendwie, die sind ein oder dasselbe. Die Logik dahinter, die State-Machine dahinter, ist immer ne ineinander verschränkte. Und du hast es außerdem noch komplizierter, wenn du plötzlich DHCP-4 und DHCP-V6, und bei DHCP-V6 gibt es dann noch ganz andere Protokolle. Auf jeden Fall, was wir uns überlegt haben, ist, wir wollen das simpel haben. Wir wollen fähig sein, diese ganzen State-Machines, die ganzen Abhängigkeiten da tatsächlich zu implementieren. Wir implementieren unsere eigenen Protokolle an der Stelle. Insbesondere, weil es nicht schwierig ist, weil DHCP so ein einfaches Protokoll ist. Was dann zum Ergebnis geführt hat, wir haben jetzt ein Library. Die kann DHCP-4, DHCP-6, die kann EPV-4-L, die kann ein paar andere Protokolle. Unsere Network-Deimplementation benutzt diese Library und nicht mehr das ISC-Z Teil. Was total toll ist, weil wir keine Abhängigkeiten dadurch haben. Ironischerweise hat der Network-Manager inzwischen auch erkannt, dass das auch ganz toll ist. Er kopiert jetzt unsere DHCP-Implementation aus Network-D und benutzt sie auch in Network-Manager, weil die auch festgestellt haben, dass es vielleicht nicht so toll ist, immer externe Programme auszuführen und nicht zu wissen, was die intern tun. Das ist nur so als Hintergrund. Weil wir aber so grundlegend irgendwie das loslegen, dass wir auch notfalls die Protokollimplementationen da machen, wenn das irgendwie notwendig ist, ist das natürlich auch alles insgesamt wieder ein Projekt, um darauf zurückzukommen, was kein Ende hat. Weil irgendwie, wenn wir das sauber machen wollen, wenn unsere Priorität ist, immer irgendwie das korrekt zu lösen und wenn es länger dauert, dann ist das halt so. Und das hat natürlich Sinn, das Ergebnis, dass andere Leute sofort Produkte delivern in vielen Ecken. Wir brauchen länger, aber irgendwie glauben wir dann schon, dass das, was wir dann abliefern, dass es dann auch länger hält. Dass es dann länger hält, ja. Aber es ist ein Luxus, den wir uns leisten können. Viele Leute haben den Luxus nicht. Das ist irgendwie, weil wir nicht direkt in einem Produktzyklen eingebettet sind. Red Hat gibt uns sehr viel Unabhängigkeit. Und es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt irgendwie jeden Monat ein Produkt daraus hauen muss. Ich bin relativ weit entfernt von irgendwie reellen Produktzyklen. Und ich arbeite dann mit den Leuten zusammen, die dann die Entscheidung treffen, was dann in den Reil reinkommt. Aber irgendwie, das ist nicht direkt in unserer Arbeit, so direkt drin. Und das finde ich auch ganz toll von Red Hat, dass sie uns die Unabhängigkeit geben.
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir es ganz gut, ganz gut abgedeckt. Auf jeden Fall ist das eine Entwicklung und ein Projekt, was, glaube ich, Linux an sich ganz neu aufstellt, was die Maschine einfach mehr über sich weiß. Ich meine, wenn wir irgendwann mal Roboterarmeen haben wollen, ist das ja ganz wichtig. Und wenn man sich jetzt auch schaut, wie sie gerade diesen Embedded-Bereich entwickelt, hier mit so Buzzwords wie Internet of Things und so weiter, ich will jetzt nicht wieder mit dem Kühlschrank anfangen, aber es ist ja klar, dass sozusagen diese ganzen Kleinstrechner, die mehr oder weniger autonom in einem sich permanent verändernden Environment, wie du auch schon bei Network D sagtest, mit irgendwie Netzverbindungen kommen und gehen und alles beeinflusst gegeneinander. Und man will halt einfach Software schreiben, die in dem Moment stabil ist. Und wenn halt schon das OS nicht stabil ist oder das System Setup nicht stabil ist, wie soll man denn da noch einen zuverlässigen Dienst anbieten? Damit hat man ja im Prinzip schon selber genug zu tun. Und das sehe ich schon auch als eine wichtige Anforderung an, gerade für Linux, das sich jetzt ja einfach so universell auch aufgestellt hat und einfach so viele Produktbereiche abdeckt. Das ist halt jetzt einfach nicht immer nur jemand, der vorm Rechner sitzt und ihnen versteht, sondern diese Systeme müssen sich jetzt irgendwie langsam auch mal selber verstehen.
Ja, das ist unheimlich wichtig. Dieses Leitbild, was wir ein bisschen haben als WSMD, ist, dass der Rechner sich auch selbst irgendwie administrieren kann. Zum großen Teil. Also das heißt, Kai, mein Kollege, der redet immer von diesem Beispiel, dass man irgendwie einen Rechner bauen sollte, den man irgendwie am Grunde des Meeres versenkt. Und der läuft dann für zwei Jahre lang durch. Und wenn ich ihn wieder raushole, soll er noch funktionieren. Und das ist irgendwie so ein Leitbild, was wir haben, dass ein Rechner, ohne dass du ihn berührst, doch bitte sehr weiter funktionieren soll. Und irgendwie in der heutigen Welt, auch wenn du ein Internet und sowas hast, heißt das dann auch, dass er sicher ist und sowas. Aber das heißt auch, dass er irgendwie kryptografisch gesichert ist, dass er nicht manipuliert werden kann. Das heißt, dass irgendwie, wenn etwas passiert, dass er sich helfen kann. Das heißt, wenn etwas passiert, dass der Teil rausisoliert wird, der nicht mehr funktioniert und der gefixt wird, also der nicht mehr funktioniert, aber der Rest weiterhin funktioniert. Das heißt, schon alleine beim Logging ist das, dass man ein richtig gutes Logging hat, dass es nicht manipulierbares Logging hat. Das heißt, eine ganze oberflächliche Sache beim Logging. Und der klassische Syslog funktioniert, Rotieren von Log-Dateien, also die alten Dateien wegschmeißen, durch Zeit und alleine durch Zeit. Das heißt, wenn irgendwas passiert und das System fängt, wie wild anzuloggen. Irgendjemand macht einen Nmap oder so von Maschine, alle Dammens sagen, hey, ich habe hier eine Verbindung, die ist sofort bended worden. Und das passiert, du findest so einen Spike von Logs. Und die Festbreite läuft voll, wegen dieser Logs. Dann wird das aufgeräumt, das nächste Mal, wenn der Rotierer wieder vorbeikommt. Und der Rotierer, der kann in einer halben Stunde vorbeikommen. Und bis diese halbe Stunde irgendwie passiert, ist die Festbreite voll.
Das wird vielleicht gar nicht mehr ausgerufen.
Das kann nicht sein. Das ist absolut unmöglich. Und das heißt, wenn man so ein Gerät bauen will, das man irgendwie mehr versenken will, dann muss man sich überlegen, okay, das Logging muss von vornherein. Das sollte gar nicht erst auf die Festbreite schreiben, wenn sie voll ist oder wenn sie voll werden könnte. Sondern es muss, wenn es feststellt, dass es jetzt mit dieser Schreiberei, die sie jetzt stattfinden würde, die Festbreite voll laufen würde, dann muss es synchron erst mal rotieren, alten Scheiß wegschmeißen, warten bis es fertig ist und dann erst auf die Festbreite schreiben. Das ist auch etwas, was wir im Journal implementiert haben, wo wir gesagt haben, das kann überhaupt nicht sein, wie die alte Technik, das muss irgendwie in dem Logging selber drin sein, dass das rotiert wird. Weil irgendwie, wenn man Geräte unbeobachtet irgendwo stehen lassen will, dann guckt da eben nicht jemand drauf und tut was, wenn die Festbreite voll läuft. Sondern dann darf die Festbreite gar nicht erst voll laufen.
Ja, Mensch, du bist ja der Horror für eingefleischte Systemstreichler.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist auch unter einem Grund, warum manche uns irgendwie nicht so glücklich mit dem Kram sind, den wir tun. Weil wir machen es eben einfacher und wir nehmen irgendwie viel von der Komplexität oder zumindest unsere Hoffnung oder zumindest unser Ziel aus dem System raus und versuchen, die teilweise irgendwie einfach komplett unnötig zu machen oder irgendwie dem System selbst beizubringen, dass es diese Probleme handeln kann.
Ja, in gewisser Hinsicht ist das auch so ein bisschen Generationswechsel. Die Dinge fangen jetzt halt an, auch nach einer Weile mal anders zu sein, als sie es immer waren. Und naja, ich meine, alter Satz, ohne Änderung, keinen Fortschritt. Entweder da tut sich halt gar nichts oder es tut sich halt mal was. Das hat Apple auch nicht anders gemacht. Also eigentlich alle Systeme, die in irgendeiner Form noch relevant sind, haben das einfach nur geschafft, indem sie halt auch einfach alten Kram weggeworfen haben.
Ich fand das immer interessant, wenn ich mit den Leuten auf so Konferenzen rede, dann ist mir mehrfach passiert, dass irgendjemand gesagt hat, ja, I don't like change. Und dann damit ankam, dass das denn mir deswegen doof sei. Aber für mich ist das eine ganz essentielle, so kategorisch zu sagen, I don't like change, ist für mich was absolut Unverständliches, weil das ist die verdammte IT-Industrie, in der wir sind. Und wenn du irgendwas hast auf der Welt, wo Change der Default ist, dann ist es sicher die IT-Industrie. Die Leute mögen halt irgendwie, die finden irgendwie in dem Bereich, für den sie sich interessieren, an dem sie entwickeln, da soll es Fortschritt geben. Alles andere soll so bleiben, wie es ist. Jetzt ist es so ein System, das für fast alle ist ja natürlich nicht... Die Leute starten ihren Rechner nicht, um Systemdli laufen zu lassen. Die starten ihren Rechner, um damit Texte zu tippen oder irgendwie einen Drucker zu benutzen oder was auch immer. Für die ist es natürlich deswegen komplett uninteressant, wenn Change stattfindet in Systemdli. Das ist uns voll bewusst, dass das, was wir machen, irrelevant ist für die meisten Menschen. Andererseits machen wir schon Change. Ich halte es ja total notwendig, dass wir das tun. Es ist mir schon klar, dass viele Leute das gar nicht so total finden.
Ich finde es immer langweilig, wenn die Dinge immer gleich bleiben.
Ja, so finde ich das auch. Ich erkenne auch anders. Ich habe früher als Web-Developer gearbeitet. Da habe ich alles in PHP gemacht. Das war eine lange Zeit. Ich verlange auch nicht, dass die Web-Developer immer noch alles in PHP machen. Ich habe festgestellt, dass sie das immer noch tun.
Das ist eine andere Problematik. Lennart, jetzt machen wir hier einen Punkt. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei CRE. Hier gibt es dann nicht so viel Change. Ich mache nämlich einfach weiter mit dem nächsten Thema demnächst. Bis dahin sage ich erst mal Tschüss und bis bald.